[Music]
do
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chelsea thrive in madrid
for the first time in 30 years
spain's capital plays host to the
candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished
business and others from the next wave
of stars with little patience for
yielding to those before them
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
it is day four round four it's the
palacio de santonia the beautiful
beautiful building
downtown in the heart of madrid
and a beautiful
beautiful interior full of art you can't
really find anywhere else
playing host
the 2022 b-day candidates
could not have a more historic
venue to host a historic event
the players will be making their way
through the palisio as usual
to take their seats in battle on the
intellectual field that is the 64 square
chess board
the players will be coming in as we know
soon and
we will be taking a look at them as they
arrive of course as usual while they get
set to come downstairs we get set in our
chairs up here
international master danny wrench here
alongside almira skripchenko once again
elmira well i want to sit in those
chairs i know you keep saying you want
to go downstairs and play i'm like hey
you're here to host but you were also
here
on the rest day hopefully enjoying
yourself what'd you get up to well one
thing of my bucket list i went to the
brother museum i suppose i spent the
whole day in the museum watching all
these paintings i've been dreaming about
this since i was a kid so rubens you
know titian
uh mario and velazquez and so many
others we'll talk about this later but
it's inspires me so much i am not going
to be able to keep up with you and your
and your great uh taste and knowledge of
art but i think i do recognize a couple
of the names of the great artists you
just mentioned i did not have as
interesting of a rest day thanks for
asking but i will tell you anyway i
basically basically hung out in my hotel
room well you asked the questions
i only got my in my in my hotel room um
chilled rested caught up on some work it
was it was pretty great so um anyway we
we uh we needed the rest we've had three
rounds and the reason we needed the rest
is because round four is ahead but
before we talk about that let's let's
remind everybody of what went down
uh in the first few days a surprise or
not surprise that the two guys who've
already played for a world championship
yonda pomnishi and fabiano caruana are
the two guys leading the field at this
point elmira well jan and fabian are
certainly in form and both of them are
looking for their second win in the
candidates tournament but
you know i wouldn't be uh so calm if
when i'm looking at the standings there
are four guys chasing them and those
four guys are duda ferruger a port and
nakamura and we also see jingle bells
at the bottom of the standings they're
struggling so far
no you're totally right obviously it's
cliche thing to say but it's true at
this point it's still anybody's game
anybody's tournament you know as i look
at the four people with one and a half
points
it's hard for me to decide who had a
tougher road who has been more
impressive on the way to get there right
ali rosa farrugia has has already played
two blacks he plays his third black out
of four games today so when you look at
that score you have to be impressed with
the young man of course everyone talking
about hikaru the fact that he he had
undeniably i think the most exciting
games round by round so far a loss of
victory this incredible draw we saw so
that's amazing but as you said we'll
digly wren you know continue to write
the ship so it's anybody's game the two
the two previous challengers napalm
mishi and caruana are right there at the
top but it is still it is still
anybody's game so uh before we before we
get set here for the
the round four matchups
let's take a look at them right
yeah let's let's have a look at the
pairings okay
quick thoughts on report versus nakamura
gotta be the report
can't think too much about that bad
record against icaru well he
he's certainly affected by this core but
i think that in this tournament well you
have to let it go and
richard rapport is going to press hard
with white and he's going to be all in
today napalmashi is leading the
tournament and has the white pieces
against the youngest player in the field
ali rezab perugia of course that's going
to have us on the edge of our seat uh
duda rajaba quick thoughts on that one
well once again uh
young sister
is having white today he it's his third
white in the tournament so he will try
to convert this against timur who is
trying to find his game still so and
duda hasn't really had any better
chances than he had in round one when he
had white as we as we saw so uh he
wasn't able to get that victory against
rapport will he will he figure out the
white pieces today and then and then the
dingley run versus five in a car wanna
you see a five to two score
obviously we know that that's been a lot
of the pre-height banter coming in of
course we're going to continue to unpack
the context of that particular match up
but uh well i had a look at those games
and actually even recently
dink has won a lot of games with white
so as you would say he has fabi's number
yeah it's bobby's number one his play
especially with white right so okay as
as we say that we want to continue to
talk about these games but let's do it
while we look at the beautiful faces of
our of our players of our champions
there's one of the gladiators himself
uh
looking looking pretty dapper in that in
that suit metal detector you know that's
like uh you know hikaru is showing his
credit cards
[Music]
of course that's what happens when
you're rocking an american express black
card hikaru when you've got the black
card it's a metal card so you have to
give it all away
that's what's happening now
i'm not going to lie hikaru i know a
hikaru and that is not a happy hikaru
about what he is being grilled about
right now he's like look it's a wallet
it's a metal credit card i'm going
through every single thing here i'm not
too thrilled about the fact that i'm
being tortured about this
and also i think that fide had a request
so for him to well to dress differently
hikaru has addressed it also on twitter
well i i find it's
[Music]
exaggerated
because so he's wearing a suit right now
but i don't think that was something
wrong you know i don't think there was
anything wrong with his outfit i agree
but i i will say this i he
there's that there's that coffee again
anyway hi chris um anyway but um
it is it is an anti-cheating measure
right obviously you know to be fair to
fidei
well it is certainly not the favorite
thing hikaru's ever done to empty his
wallet how many cards he has a lot of
credit cards
obviously trying to detect whether
there's any metal of any other kind
besides a wallet for good reason uh we
want to make sure that all the players
are completely clean uh but okay you
could tell that that was that was an
interesting process to go through glad
we caught it on camera let's talk about
what we might catch on the board here
report is white so even though he's got
this 0-3 record against zakar with a
couple draws sprinkled in he does have
the first move today elmira
well and there he is well i've done my
homework and you will be surprised but
richard report was the one who played
the last decoration that delirio
zafaruza used against hikaru and i think
that we will be able to show it to you
yeah later today that's right
teaser alert we might have a nice little
breakdown for you of some things we
learned about that epic epic ferocious
preparation and then an epic epic
defense by hikaru nakamura so so another
rockstar another rock star with a
pinstripe looking suit it looks like a
uh an italian cut of some kind as a guy
who knows very little about most of the
things he talks about on tv i know even
less about suits
and do you know daniel that all the
tickets were sold for this tournament in
24 hours this is like
to see the stars
we have some other players to see as
well um
report and nakamura will be an
interesting battle but
fabiano makes his way he did looks like
he just got up that is a jacket and an
emblem many people know of the chess
club and scholastic center in st louis
one that favi sports proudly
uh he's
he's gonna have the black pieces
in this in this battle and go back to
what you quickly said when we had the
the the visual of the pairings up it's
not just that dingley wren has the plus
record against faviano it's that he has
a very good grip on him when he's white
exactly and uh dingorian won his uh well
his last game with white against fabiano
classical in the last candidates which
lasted for over a year so it still was
two years ago but um
i think that fabiano is also choosing
quite a different opening against
englering every time so he's well
he's not sure
yeah but he can't seem to escape no
matter what fabi does with black dingley
wrens seems to be well prepared as white
and something about the style of these
two guys i feel like if we see fobby
playing white in the second half of the
tournament we might be saying a
different kind of thing but i i do
expect ding to maybe get an edge and
press just if history uh repeating is is
something that happens here today so
interesting shot here we see only report
and nakamura at their boards um
everybody else
oh and there's there's tame over jabba
but everyone else apparently has some
better things to do but
these chairs do look impressive i i know
as i you know as i have a closer look at
them like i understand things reactions
so you do not feel comfortable
in the chairs yes in these chairs
it's more of a gamer chair yeah well
it's got it it's got the tall back and
the top neck it is more of a gamer's
chair speaking of gamers chair yonder
palm rishi has a very impressive looking
gamer's chair one of the few top grand
masters who's streamed not as much as
hikaru but he does from time to time but
okay let's let's talk about this one i i
know dingley ren fabiano caruana
maybe he's had a lot of pre-hype focus
but i really think this matchup here
yonda pomneshi ali perugia is going to
be the one that gets us fired on board
today elmira
well and jan has a lot of things to
prove i think after the world
championship match he uh he took sort of
like a spiritual retreat he didn't play
a lot yeah so did i leave for russia
uh they both of them wanted to
well to analyze their games maybe
well their weaknesses who knows you know
and to
to come back even stronger that's an
interesting point because two very
different paths right yana pomnashi lost
to magnus carlson in dubai for the world
chess championship ali reza perugia was
qualifying right around that time in the
grand swiss but you're right these are
two guys who have played
the least i guess coming into the
candidates compared to all the other
players so
um how will that affect their
preparation
yonda pomnishi may be going to try to
bring something
out of the bag of tricks he didn't get
to use against carlson in dubai against
alireza perhaps
here's dingley run again and i wanted
well to to say that they haven't played
of course that many classical games as
well against each other so well i've
looked at some of the statistics and the
games they were playing online
and young wins quite often yeah jan has
had a good score against alireza online
but okay on to dingley ren who who
finally comes to the the table along
with alireza sorry how long with fabiana
garwana so many games um
well here he is the top player from
china if there's if there's any
way if there's any time for for stella
to get her groove back if you will for
dingley wren to find its form
against fabiano
with the first move
a position where he's been confident
before and familiar you know he's
familiar with this chair and and uh
and he's often got he's often gotten
good results so okay before the games
are played now that we've taken a look
at all four quickly
we get to take a look at the vote chess
and uh we're gonna we're gonna cast a
vote i
i'm gonna say that ding gets the victory
i'm gonna shock the world on that one
i'm gonna go with a draw and report
nakamura
i'm gonna go with a victory for yon
against alireza for ruja i don't have to
vote and i'm gonna go for another draw
fourth draw in a row for young
christophe duda there those are my quick
picks remember use the command guess and
you will get a direct link to do so you
can also just go to chess.com events
yourself there's cash prizes
there's diamond memberships there's all
kinds of stuff at stake um i went
through that fast i don't even i mean
i kind of blacked out a little bit we'll
see whether my results come through or
not but we're about to have our first
moves and we didn't want to miss it
so your thoughts uh well uh you know the
last game uh fabi played uh
slav you know and he sacrificed two
pounds do you remember and ding was
walking all over the board with his king
it was
a crazy game it was exciting
go.chess.com
candidates guess is the direct url but
again just use the command guest if
you're watching whether it be on youtube
twitch or anywhere else
you'll get a direct link and you can go
get some cash prizes and some diamond
memberships
and look at this
is it is it going to be d4 i thought we
would maybe we don't know yet we don't
know i wonder if that was a
when did this tradition start of players
telling arbiters a move that they don't
intend to play like when did that first
start you know you're that you're the
historian here do you have any info on
that well first of all it started with
the uh media attention that was brought
like to the chess world and the
the symbolical first move is like the
symbolical first kick you have this
football baseball yeah
the same so
but then uh well you have to play with
your opponent a little bit yep
to mess with his head so you have to
maybe a3 or b3 would be more appropriate
in those under those circumstances here
we go we well it was not it was not a
troll in this game though turns out um
it was just uh just his plan he plays d4
often i i have a visual of these two
guys playing in in italians and in
complex spanish games but as i as i
recall on those games i realized that
fabiano was probably white in most those
games when fabiano's white they get a
lot of those e4 e5 double king pawn
theoretical battles he might go for
catalan and knight c3 you think this is
one of the surprises because ding likes
to play catalan positions very much so
g3 yeah just just to show and
the catalan would have been would have
been g3 instead of knight c3
for those wondering on the reference
elmira made but so far we're still just
in regular open theory we've actually
transposed into a vergozin
queen's gambit declined
and look at this dingus thinking you
know he is not yeah he wasn't expecting
it's possible
not very uh
not very likely that ding is surprised
on any theoretical level remember at
this point everybody of course he knows
the regards and well uh but
maybe not expecting fabiano to go for a
ragosan
bobby plays lots of different
traditional queens gambit declines but
there goes in itself just to give a
quick macro of what it means it's the
def it's defined by the bishop coming to
b4 versus let's say the traditional
bishop e7 in a queen's gambit so this is
this is an aggressive approach um and
queen a4 check is a move that forces
black to put the knight on a square that
you normally don't want the knight on
because you have to guard the bishop due
to the check so
obviously we're going to keep our eye on
this theoretically and and add some
context but this is uh interesting to
see that ding took pause there before
going into the main line with queen a4
well it's also considered to be very
solid lines yeah
so let's um
maybe let's give an overview of uh like
every game
yeah yeah no and we're gonna we're gonna
continue to look at all the games here
as soon as we can we'll get you caught
up on the openings of the other games
but i'm
i'm just i'm just wondering
why do you think we'll we'll look into
it we'll see whether these two guys have
ever played over goes in before but uh
we we see the move queen c2 now this is
still very much theory let me just point
out that this eval bar because this is a
little bit of a new feature for for many
people tuning in if you hold your mouse
over it cool little feature we've added
is that while the games are still in the
opening it actually tells you the
percentages of how often the positions
how what the results are and how often
they've been played that is until you
see a novelty once you see no okay
knight a5 right now the computer is is
trying to look into whether there's
opening explorer games but the moment
we're out of the opening that's when we
switch to the traditional eval bar well
i don't know how you do this i can
barely look at the position because i'm
like glued to it i'm trying to figure
out then you have this feature here this
feature there yeah
well i i almost just look at the colors
i'm just a color guy you know visual guy
just as long as i see that it still has
a gray in the middle i'm like oh we're
still in the opening stage the moment it
switches i go wait a second we're in
novel territory and i think we have to
pause and really appreciate that because
we are on move seven and fabiano has
played a move that
has never been played before according
to the opening score and certainly has
taken dingley wren by surprise that's
exactly what what i wanted to tell you
because like i saw knight a5 and i'm
thinking oh my god like yeah i have no
clue once yeah i have no clue what
what's going on here so like i uh well i
know that's you know there was several
moves in this position b6 also one of
those and
uh but knight day five what a
winning surprise this is it's a
principled move that hits the c4 pawn to
try to force a decision so we understand
it we'll come back and look at the
opening theory in a little bit in the
meantime let's back out and
get our first
sort of high-level look at what's going
on in all four games we'll choose which
which way we're going but let's just
pause here and look real quick on
judo for jabba interesting one report
nakamura
a looks like looks like it was a
an e4 e5 anti-berlin as well
but i think we should head over to
napalm to shivaruja because that's uh
maybe this will be the english attack
that delivers for the excitement i
wanted uh on day three elmira
i can't wait for that yes we were
discussing this opening the night of
yesterday and uh fearuja didn't go for
the move h5 used by dude yesterday just
yeah he played the traditional so
um
amir is referring to this position where
john christoph duda played h5 against
fabiano caruana just slow down g4 ali
reza instead
plays bishop e7 and queen d2 and castle
so this is the
this is the main main line right and one
of the things we highlighted about h5
elmira is h5 slows down white's attack
but it also comes at the risk of opening
up your king
so once you put the king there you will
almost never see a move like h5 played
anymore we're going to see a traditional
english attack here so here we have in
like a classical position
in the nighter defense with the opposite
castle you know so
who is going to be
at the citadel first i would like to say
yes yeah this
okay this this is really uh mainline
stuff so the players playing quickly
here and i cannot wait to see what the
novelty is in this game everyone why
because it probably won't be a novelty
until we're in the mid-20s at least like
this looks like a game where the players
are going to be playing
a lot of opening theory uh for some time
so
knight bd7 g4 and here goes g4
so white launches
is the first to launch the attack
so
this was the structure i was hoping we
were going to get in fabiano uh young uh
young christophe duda so let's let's
maybe talk a little bit about the
structure here to set the stage what's
going to happen before we look at others
real quick
well i just wanted to say that normally
we'll reply with b5 of course g4 b5 is
uh very natural so here you can try and
chase the knight first play g5
immediately he does so okay he does so
and
black has two main moves here to move
the knight or to play b4 first
okay but i i was most thinking about
knight h5 but you know you see it like
believers proves me wrong yes typically
in this line they do they do favor b4 i
i think i think because now if knight d5
comes you can take with the knight
and then play bishop f5
and okay this is still just a ton of
theory so i'm not saying like black
favors this because black's better or
anything like that but
this particular move order white now has
to make a move usually rook g1 or
something before you can play bishop d3
because the trade on d3 if the queen
takes sometimes this g5 pawn is still
hanging so this move order works out a
little bit for black um but okay right
on the cue though jan
plays the move knight to e2
what i wanted to say is i wanted to use
this moment also to point out that uh
this move before is very important
because uh like while you're while
you're attacked if you have a chance to
create your own threats yes you have to
use this moment yeah no that's a really
good point for elmira because any time
you're looking at a position just like
this king's on opposite sides of the
board
both sides rushing ahead every time you
have a chance to gain a tempo
that's usually a good thing because your
pieces need to get as close as they can
to this king uh before your opponent
does the same on the other side of the
board so
g5 met with b4 the knight comes to e2
and we see that we've already had
another move for molly reza in 98.
so not not night age five yeah
okay
well this is this is going to be a a
theoretical battle for the ages ali reza
ferrugia not afraid of whatever yonda
palmishi has prepped in this english
attack and we're going to come back to
it a little bit and see where it's
evolved to
backing up again there are two games we
haven't looked at yet everybody due to
rajabov
and report nakamura
let's have a look i think we'll go there
what do you think elmira
another g5
it's uh well i i wanted to make a joke
it seemed that he covered spent like
some time at a camp you know where he
was trained to be a gladiator you know
but in
some kind of chess dystopia you know
with no bones in front of his kings you
know so this like
happens again so right right as you said
hikaru spent time at the camp the dream
became a gladiator he perfect timing he
looked at the camera as if he heard and
kind of
gave a little bit of a nod as if
confirming that he heard you like you're
not wrong elmira uh camp gladiator
exists anyway but okay jokes aside yeah
this is the yet another time
where hikaru as black has played g5
early against against fabiano obviously
he did it against fabruja and was met
with the sacrifice that we saw on sunday
before the rest day
this is not going to be a sacrifice but
this is just a very aggressive way for
black to play in this position and
and is the is the e5 pawn
capturable here like am i am i allowed
to take this one i mean
i want to you want to let's see because
i wanted to go h5 here because it's
certainly hikarus point and that's the
point in these positions all the time
but can we just go back at bishop c6
gtx6 at the opening stage because yes
you can remember you know fabiano played
a little bit differently so actually
richard airport first of all starts with
e4 this game you know there is a
dramatic change
he is targeting hikaru's preparation
another point so he's going for the same
opening as fabian used against hikar in
the first round so
goes for the same structure bishop c6 he
gives up
his bishop
and you know fabiana used the plan with
knight bd2 knight beast three yeah so
uh richard you know
goes for castling of course first and
then
here after bishop g6
uh he goes for bishop g5 yeah
which is kind of a typical idea when the
bishop isn't going to be on on the
square e7 dwight
so again first of all really important
that we highlighted elmira pointed out
again knight d2 was played instead of
castles by caruana against nakamura on
day one but despite fabiano getting the
win report wants to do something
different
bishop g5
h6 bishop h4
or was it first castle knight bd2 i
still don't remember like no no it was
like that's right
okay but here of course it's a typical
idea when you play
well well you want to unpin but it
offers also you a possibility to to be
very aggressive starting from the
opening with black
and hikari is using it immediately you
know it's there are not very many
positions where you can you can do this
yeah so bishop g5 h6 g5
bishop g3
and now bishop b6 we need uh to analyze
this line so that's a that's a
it's a fun move and a move that hikaru
is playing quickly by the way putting
rapport into the think tank i mean this
this is
okay so
i'm not wrong that knight takes e5 is a
move even the computer agrees it's a
move but almira is right that likely h5
will be the prep from hikaru looking to
go all in on a king side attack before
white has not only completed development
but
but but maybe maybe
prepare to defend on the king side this
this would be a fun one to see it's not
like it's just over though because you
can move the knight
and you're not getting the bishop trap
because this trade happens
so
that wouldn't necessarily be what uh
black wants to do if the knight comes to
f3
maybe you can oh i don't know if you can
take first but then if i take with the
f-bomb i think i think maybe and then
you try to get castled long as quickly
as you can right to launch an attack no
here i want to play h4 but i was looking
at f take g3 first because here i'm
going to talk
because here it seems uh that black has
sufficient compensation too well to
immediately so i was thinking that here
you could use queen d4 check so after g4
then knight probably goes to h4
we'll go here just to show how bad it is
no no yeah
queen d4 check yes you have knight g5 on
a knight h4 but yeah this one as well
you're look
what
interesting you also have knight takes
e4 by the way because the pawn is pinned
oh this i haven't seen you know i do not
allow those things in my games go like
on the normal square
oh my gosh this is okay
another wild game ahead of us another
really aggressive approach from hikaru
on the king side but
uh one player who we haven't had a
chance to get to know a little more
might as well take the opportunity to do
so right now because he's on the clock
uh richard report thinking for almost
seven minutes already let's take a
closer look before he makes his next
move in our latest chess.com player
profile
[Music]
playing some of his best chess richard
report steps into this year's candidates
with reasonable expectations to place
well throughout his career report has
been no stranger to the top 10 in the
world rankings
using his solid performances at the
series of fide grand prix events reports
secured his first bid to the candidates
the hungarian-born competitor is looking
for his first opportunity to become a
challenger for the world championship
reports surged past the 2700 barrier
before he reached 19 years old known for
his offbeat openings report is also
considered by many as the most
unpredictable opening innovator in the
field
also unpredictable is the current status
for which country report will be
representing hungarian-born report is in
the process of moving his chest
allegiances to romania either way report
would be the first from hungary or
romania to win the candidates
richard report
one of the most interesting characters
in the event for sure uh obviously
daniel highlighted some interesting
points a lot of interesting points but
especially one about his federation
switch recently elmira has so much to
talk about but we look at the three
draws he's had so far
we shouldn't discount that he might have
even had an opportunity to get a win
yesterday oh sorry i keep saying
yesterday my apologies it's going to be
a long a long few weeks in madrid on
sunday but your thoughts on what stood
out to you not just uh in his first
three games elmira but in our player
profile about report well um maybe first
of all like in this tournament uh
richard missed a few opportunities of
course but um i feel that he has such a
fighting spirit and this is what is the
most it's one of the most important
qualities for this tournament
he's just in his games are so creative
and
well you're never disappointed so
i think that he
might be actually a perfect challenger
for magnus carlsen
i'm looking at this uh well statistics
he certainly doesn't have a perfect
score against hikaru
but for example if hikaru would have to
qualify he doesn't have a perfect score
against magnus either so you know it's
even worse it's like i think 1 to 14. so
you know it doesn't really say anything
it's just
you
will rise to the challenge
well of course because we know a match
is so different than any tournament
anyway we and we talked about that
because let's be real a lot of story
line going into napolishi carlson was
that yawn had a plus record against
magnus but everyone who unpacked that
stat said okay napan rishi has a good
record against carlson but a world
championship match totally different
animal totally different amount of time
you have to prepare so i think you're
making a great point that because of
reports creative style because of his
willingness to mix it up if he was in a
match setting where he had a group of
seconds around him right where he had
time to prepare what would he be capable
of in a match like that
i would not mind seeing that and that's
actually i think one of the reasons why
richard uh took this uh very difficult
decision uh well i imagine to switch
federation because he was given this
support you know he will be able to
build that team to train
for 10 hours a day so if he wants
i think well this this is a very
important factor
i didn't do you have any inside
information on that was that part of
like what he was able to
secure as his federation switching and
no but i can imagine this like for me
it's it's a very difficult decision you
know it's a life-changing decision so uh
i think that he he was given the support
by the main sponsor
in romania well that makes sense i think
a lot of people from the outside looking
in and one and wonder you know why why a
change now right you're you're you're
hungarian-born you know chess grand
master that has been your federation
forever why would you be motivated to
change romania but it makes a lot of
sense right if you have an opportunity
to take your career to the next level
however that support might be coming in
um
and like you said if he was in a spot
where he was preparing for a match and
got that kind of support
what would he be capable of
um
all right danny you just if we could go
back uh yeah let's you know what he's
capable of let's let's analyze this game
a little bit because we had a move from
nakamura
we had two moves from nakamura um
no basically like let's get back to the
position where
he has sacrificed upon we went through
95 i just wanted to show why bishop e5
was not possible yeah bishop e5 is the
other way to capture but bishop v5 would
not be as good
maybe simply queen d4 is in the in the
variation that we've seen uh previously
and queen b2
what do you think
and then cast i'm not sure if you can
castle along there maybe like even with
the open b file maybe you can cast so
long what do you think like i think so
mainly because queen b2 let's say knight
bd2 can you castle along here that's
that was my question let's do it
i know you're talking to a sicilian
player here so you're asking me can i
castle into danger
yes
okay so i guess you're asking the wrong
guy um
white or black but
but okay jokes aside i think it i think
it is possible because even though the b
file is open i think you could still
argue that
black's attack is probably coming faster
than whites here white's pieces aren't
well coordinated to quickly jump over
here
and so you cannot play knight c4 i will
simply take it simply lose a piece
because the pawn is pinned to the lady
on d1
um rook b1 mike and even
and something like this probably the
queen doesn't doesn't take a2 you go to
you go to one some other square
and
again we would have a lot of a lot of
things to talk about in this game i
would not be unhappy if we get something
like this king's on opposite sides of
the board
but we see in the game report recognizes
that he doesn't want to take with either
the knight because of h5 or the bishop
instead plays the solid queen d2 nice
preparation from tim hikaru yeah knight
to d7 and now d4
and hikaru is
i think that he's going to play f6
because first of all this is a standard
reaction and he already used it against
fabi yeah
uh well the context was a little bit
different but the same idea you're right
same idea yeah
and quincy two but this is also such a
odd looking move at first
it's funny yeah because
the queen
looks misplaced there especially with
the knight undeveloped but in many ways
it makes sense that the queen may have
chances to jump into the center at some
point also you free the d1 square for
the rook earlier than you normally would
in case firepower is needed on the
d-file um
it's interesting i
it's it's obviously original territory
um for anyone following theoretically
we'll we'll get some some stats here in
fact
we've got some stats being confirmed by
our own peter dockers right now so
apparently nine bishop to e6 was a
novelty it would make sense because that
was where we saw report spot pause and
think
right um
so no surprise there that bishop e6 was
the first move and as you said good prep
from team hikaru although even with even
with prep almira
kind of thematic ideas right you already
said similar to what he did against fabi
we'll probably see a position that's
centered around the tension of of what
what happens here
can white break through on the dark
squares and maybe expose these moves as
weaknesses or is black able to keep
things closed long captioning not
neither on available knight or c3 so
there must be a point behind so
if you play f6 um
well i was looking at queen c3 but it
looks very strange here to me as well
because there are the similar ideas in
why to
well i think of it in wrestling sicilian
which i play very often you have the
same kind of structures and uh white is
attacking the pawn on e5 but playing
like queen d2 queen c3 actually so if we
can extrapolate you know so i'm showing
it on the board because i think you
might be onto something because if we're
almira's instincts are whenever you see
a mysterious move queen d2 is definitely
mysterious
it makes sense that there's a very
unique or specific purpose and this idea
of maybe putting the queen on c3 i bet
elmira has spotted exactly what that
mysterious idea is because the knight
can develop later and that queen is
perfectly primed to put pressure on all
the right spots so
all right there's one game el mir we
haven't okay we haven't looked at yet by
the way hicaro has played f6 so you're
you're one for one of predictions we'll
see if you're two for two with queen to
c3 um
but obviously we know that there's a
there's a fourth game as we look at the
the uh
the flavor of ice cream before us today
we've got so many exciting games i can't
wait to get into them duda imra java is
the only other one that we have not
looked at yet
so let's do so right now
um
the
opposite here as far as opening theory
just real quick context we see a novelty
early on by nakamura this this position
we won't even talk too much about it
because obviously we're looking at a
four
four nights i mean this is about its
classical chess as it gets elmira for
beginners looking at right king pawns
everybody's developed all their minor
pieces everyone's controlling the center
beginners take note of the quality chess
before you in this game with duda versus
rijaba
well
first things first then let's have a
look at the opening uh young sister dude
uh chose d3 once again because he wanted
to avoid the berlin defense
so he didn't want to go for the end game
which uh well appears on the board after
let's say if you play castle94
and
what is interesting about this position
is this move knight c3
okay
it's
it's a completely different move order
than
we usually see
first we go c3 you know
we don't give the option of playing
knight d4 a little bit later so knight
bd2 knight f1 but here yeah the
difference is that the bishop was
developed very early on g5 once again
yes so he wants to play uh knight c3
knight d5 a very simple idea
you see
and then uh
we'll just show it for fun
if you're not careful and it may not
even work right away
but
if you have a pin on the king's side
like this and your opponent can bring a
knight to d5
sometimes you desperately wish you could
put your bishop back on e7 it doesn't
work here partly because white isn't
castle jets black can actually be
aggressive with the move g5 um
and uh
okay so knight g5 is losing knight takes
g5 i believe this must be the movie okay
knight takes d5 it's a reverse a pin
sometimes becomes a reverse sort of
discovery but if
if it wasn't for that idea the point is
this is just a good tactic to kind of be
aware of that if somehow if somehow your
opponent can bring extra firepower to a
pin on the king side things can become
very bad very quickly um but as amir
said knight to c3
spying that square looking to bring
pressure on f6
and rajava is taking a bit of a think
so which is very interesting uh once
again is that white uh haven't castle
yet
that gives offers sometimes a very
unique opportunity especially with this
move order knight c3 knight is coming to
d5 to play g4
so maybe not immediately here but if you
castle here you know you have to
consider this option
and also maybe not immediately maybe
h3g4 but this looks very dangerous so
or queen d2 castle long here maybe that
is what he is thinking that's the plan
knight c3 maybe queen d2 castle also so
we are having the once again a very
dangerous position with the opposing
customers
how many opposite side castling games
might be have today who knows right um
this uh that would be a lot of fun but
again this is such a modern idea right
with computer influence over some of
these classical openings you look at
these positions differently than you
used to because the the beginning people
who set the table for all of us in chess
history were we're just playing the the
simple moves right get the king out of
the center and then we'll figure it out
but now we look at moves like h6 very
differently we know that that pawn can
never return so you're already spying
ideas
like ultra aggressive stuff to cast
along even at the risk of even losing
the pawn in some positions right because
the rook will take the g file so i i
love i love what you said there because
there's a reason for java has paused
here everyone it's not
it's a classical looking position almost
looks too simple there is a lot of very
dangerous things potentially facing him
if he makes a wrong step here
well
i would be thinking too you know
playing my first candidate you would be
thinking playing your first game he's
not his first candidates for java one of
the most experienced players but it is
his first time facing young christian
duda in the candidates so all right
we've taken a look at all four games
we've uh we've uh
seen many
i i'm i'm so glad that uh
the crew here just already put
napomneshi on camera here because i'm
looking at that english attack and
just excited to dive into the theory it
looks like maybe ali rezafaruja has been
the first to surprise
uh his uh
his opponent there with this interesting
idea with d5
so that was the last move played on the
block black has played this move d5 and
nepo normally you would continue with f6
you're the sicilian player yes you have
to
open everything
there are some sacrifices you make in
the sicilian with your eyes closed and
then you ask questions later oh right
you just you just do it and because you
know you have no choice but to open up
these lines
and we'll we'll we'll get into that
variation as soon as we have the board
up but well yeah yonder palm beach what
no i was wanted to say that tal made
made it look so easy you know whenever
there is a sicilian and especially there
was one game which is coming uh to my
mind this one actually there was a game
by the way yes we are predicting
a lot here mutually together this this
is it's what i said you play this move
and then you look at the camera look at
the camera
smile for mom yawn smile for mom and
then you get back to the chest
um
okay
well just wanted to say the reason we're
saying this everyone is that
kings on opposite sides of the board
positions
you have to there's all kinds of things
we value in chess dynamically obviously
you value checkmate at the peak of every
pyramid right then we value large
amounts of material then maybe you get
in this these gray areas where sometimes
small amounts of material can be valued
less than what we call the initiative
right and in positions when the kings
are on opposite sides of the board those
are the exact type of positions where
the initiative might be worth more than
a pawn and so a move like f6 is a move
you've just played because your goal is
like look i don't even care how you're
taking that next you have three pieces
you can do it i know that the only way
white is going to get the pressure that
he needs in this game is to open up
lines and then try to do everything he
can to throw the entire army at this
side of the board and so as it is a joke
in fact in the as a dragon player i also
shame to say i played the dragon for way
longer than i should it's like
sacrificing your b-pawn in the dragon
right when you have a bishop on this
diagonal as black and you have an open
file if you could just magically take
that pawn off the board in a lot of
positions your position is just
legitimately better without the pawn so
it's just important strategically to
understand why you see players at this
level sacrificing material black is
sacrificing a pawn to open up lines and
yawn doesn't even want the pawn he's
sacrificing a pawn right back to open up
lines and ali reza has already captured
it so
oh man almira i am excited about this
game this game is what i've been waiting
for this is my english attack sicilian
finally arrived
well i think both players have they have
such a potential of creating cows yeah
so like
both of them together combined here it
is i did call that one i said we would
have fire on board in this game this
this is this is the game i think that is
going to get us hopefully not a 35 move
four straw that looks crazy hopefully
it's real real spicy well that's what i
wanted to say who analyzed this position
deeper because yeah well for for the
moment i think they're still following
their preparation
and
one thing that's um i wanted to add that
while you're sacrificing the bonds
you're also gaining squares for your
pieces you know knight g3 knight f5
knight h5 this is very important you are
opening all the diagonals look this
moves f6 obtained everything like bishop
h3 bishop b5 f5 is also possible then um
and the knight on c1 for the moment is
for me is much better than his
counterpart on e8 because it protects
everything that's a really great point
in fact this is like the
the reverse square of who said it was it
towel or coarse noise said with a knight
on f8 there is no checkmate this is sort
of
white's f8 if you will with a king on on
b1 with a knight on c1 black has no fun
oh my god i just made that up what a
great rhyme with the night on c1 black
has no fun i'll be here all week
everybody don't you fret um
but almira you know again makes a really
good point that who is
who's more prepared that's what we don't
know yet right they're both still
playing very quickly uh speaking of the
preparation and what was new on this
game once again shout out to the team
helping us with these stats according to
our own uh again chess journalist
extraordinaire extraordinaire peter
dockers he said that
in this particular game
for rouges 15 bishop to c4
instead of the move a4
has only been played 11 of 632 games now
it must have been the move before okay
sorry it was this position this move a5
here has not been played as often as as
other moves and so this is maybe the
beginning of getting us into some
original looking territory
um
but it looks very natural though yeah
a5 a4
yeah f4 a5
f5 was played
and then okay okay sorry no it was this
position that uh that the peter was
referring to
farouza played bishop to c4 that has
only been played 11 games of 632 instead
of the move a4
so
a4 is normally the move here there are
still hundreds of games in this position
faruga chooses to move bishop to c4
and obviously we're getting novel
territory that
that is that is about to get as crazy as
as you can get in any of these sicilians
but interesting facts there that it was
it was for ruja who really kind of
deviated first with this move bishop c4
instead of the move a4 but once again
these are the two moves possible in this
position you cannot ignore it so
while both players were certainly
certainly aware of this move so
if not a4 then bishop c4 is the next
plausible yes no logical move of course
so
uh you need to take on f6 here with uh
which knight danny
you have three possible captures
bishop of six knight d of six knight ef6
and this might give you a headache
yeah and again um
let's play these positions with so many
so many games for both sides
it's such a tough decision because if
you take with this knight it feels like
you're fixing your worst piece
quote-unquote the piece on the back rank
but then you're leaving g7 open right so
i'm not saying it immediately is good
but immediately you're looking at ideas
like this okay and the computer kind of
likes it right because now g7 has no
protection which means by the way queen
g5 and mate is on the board like it's
threatened and even if you take here
there's rook to g1 in a lot of these
positions and g7 is just you're just
crushing through so just to show you how
dangerous these positions are take a
snapshot yes the position is equal right
now
but
if you take with this knight
now you've given up g7 but if you take
it the other night
you keep an eye on this but you keep
this long-term dysfunction whenever the
major pieces are not communicating
there's always a chance for tactics to
go wrong so
if i had to guess he will take with this
knight because i think that line i just
showed is is actually maybe dangerous
but i don't i don't really have an
answer and once once again if you take
with well whatever the night is after
knight f6 bishop h6 maybe there is a
possibility like let's say knight df6
uh this one let's uh protect with the
knight on e8 the g7 square so knight df6
that yeah
so if i play bishop h6 here maybe i can
even take on e4 you see that's
that's also the name well now you can
because here there is no rook g1 because
the knight guards it exactly so maybe uh
this is a possible explanation
uh otherwise after bishop f6 maybe
bishop h6 uh
yeah i don't think you can take with the
bishop i just
or knight g3 even like like we said
like i could i could maybe take the pawn
i could maybe play knight g3 like i
i don't i don't i think your instincts
were right that you have to take with
the knight and the more i look at the
more i'm pretty confident will be this
one because of what you just pointed out
this knight is is now critical to
black's defense so but then knight g3
let's say knight f6 knight g3 once again
okay
and still threatening bishop h6 or g1
and protecting the e4 pawn as well at
the same time so uh
how are you going to so king h8 maybe
it's a very yes it's a very natural
defensive move all right well there's no
way we're going to be able to get to
anything deeper than these players will
it'll be exciting to learn more about
what they've what they've cooked up at
home i'll leave us with one more teaser
um
we'll come back we'll come back to the
teachers on that one because i actually
want to get back over to the dingley
wren fabiano caruana battle
i'm given that
we started with that one probably gave
it the least amount of attention
and now they we've seen
we've seen many moves on the board we're
going to have to dive into the analysis
of that one and see um
see how we got here
kind of a typical rugosin idea we can
already see with the move c5 having been
played for white this is
something that you see in these
structures and you can tell that knight
came to c6
like it doesn't normally want to do in a
qgd i.e the bergozen
but um
but fabi's on the clock here
and this is such a powerful chain you
know sometimes when you're looking at
the position it reflects the
well a simple war battlefield and you
know whenever you have this powerful
chain formation
uh these are the warriors
yeah it's really like used by greeks
romans and
i like i like where humanity has evolved
if we used to have voyeurs um killing
each other in glady and gladiator
fashion and large coliseums now we have
people
peacefully battling it out
intellectually over a chessboard um you
know
as much as i love a good russell crowe
movie i like i like where we're at here
a little better
well i think that's a lot of
philosophers agreed on this that you
know sports is sort of uh replaced you
know this form of aggression yes sport
and gaming replace violence in a lot of
a lot of very healthy ways we hope that
that continues to be a trend for
humanity
knock on wood all right let's let's dive
in here actually to some analysis
because i want to see how we got here
this is uh
we left the position elmira with queen
to c2
knight d5
yeah and then knight a5 and uh
the
the prep we have here team says so
knight a5 has actually only been played
in one other over the board game it's
not a full novelty because it's been
played a couple of online games as well
but
there's a good reason that ding paused
there on 985 we see he's down by about
13 minutes on the clock um
because he didn't quite know what to do
there let's see how he handled it he
played c5
well he forces you to make a decision
first of all with the pawn because it's
very important because if you take on d5
uh then i will have uh
well once again a very
uh
thematical exchange and the structure in
the center
so uh this is what fabi is actually he
was trying to achieve here he was
forcing either to
for white to play c5 or to take on d5 so
take on g5 is like
the simplification simplification it's
also a very typical structure but for
fabi's
goal i guess would be that now the
bishop is open right you have a little
more freedom you have both c6 and c5 on
the agenda in these types of positions
so ding decides not to give bobby that
clarity and instead play c5 and c5 of
course is the move which you play when
you want to claim an advantage with
white yeah it's not like c takes defies
you you say i don't know what to do you
know okay let's clear the waters
it will be a column game but cfar c5 you
know that this is going to be a fight a
fight yeah i love that so c5 played
doesn't clarify things black still has
this bishop sorry the bishop to solve
and now we immediately see b6 as a
response
the knight comes to c4 i love this idea
from five i don't know where this is
going and obviously white is still
finding the light position but if we if
we just added you know the evolution of
the idea as you said elmira right nine
on a5 forces a decision forces a
decision you have two decisions you can
push or you can take if you take you
help me solve the bishop problem c5
doesn't help me solve it but now when i
put my knight on c4 i'm trying to force
you to help me solve it because if you
take it i will take back with the pawn
and that diagonal is forever open for my
for my previously bad light square
bishop so
it's a very interesting idea from bobby
at home and we see he's although he's
thinking right now he earned about a
15-minute time advantage on the clock
before this turn started
so what was played after knight c4 a3
was rather forced we get the bishop
make the trade
and after a5 brook to c1
we've caught up
with the live position
so actually fabi fabi was at
an hour and 55 minutes at the start
of this turn
so he had earned actually 20 minutes
as an advantage on the clock and
it's
maybe doesn't mean anything obviously
dingley wren is um looking confident and
feeling feeling better now maybe about
facing fabi's early night a5
um
what is
the positional idea
of
a5 does he want to play bishop a6
do you think of course a5 also it's one
of the uh standard moves which you which
you play
in this position in order to exchange
after b4 8xb takes b but does he want to
play bishop basics or this is way too
dangerous here
the
i i would guess what he's worried about
is that is there some sort of just
immediate threat to open the files and
and enter in with the queen right um
i mean bishop h6 bishop a6 rook is six
and then take on b6 and then uh queen c7
immediately
yeah something like this
and you're controlling the c file
forever
and yeah that's that's kind of the point
everyone is as tame as this looks you're
like what you're afraid of a queen trade
offering whenever there's only one open
file on the board whoever controls said
file
controls the uh the fate of the game if
you will right because
this position is really very very tough
for black i love i love it when you see
simple positions because i think they're
really educational to show just the
geometry of chess that's very dangerous
and interesting because when i was
teaching students actively i always said
that open files were like commodities
which is supply and demand right
different than stocks because
commodities the value of something goes
up the less there is right so when
there's only one open file whoever
controls it
literally can win the game because of
that only file and in this type of
position white is playing king e2 and
bringing the rook over and you'll note
that black just black doesn't even have
time to challenge because by the time
you get there white still owns the file
and so this is a really instructive
example of i think beginner players look
at this and go oh this is boring it's
simple the queens are off the board
there's nothing to do here but the
subtle point that these rooks are
disconnected and that y controls the
only open file is
arguably enough for the best players in
the world to win a game just that
we have a move oh my god he played
bishop a6
what is favi going for here i just i
simply wanted to say first that rook c1
is
well anticipating this uh exchange so
maybe we'll have this position ah but
then maybe he doesn't want to change the
queens so if you take on b6 uh they're
gonna be six queen c7 and i will do well
it's an awkward move but maybe queen uh
aids let's see i like that
or you know what else i mean so i was i
was proving the instructor point about
the open file you could you could
actually play this right away and that
would already be a shoot just notice the
one difference there is that you know
now
now you're actually yeah you can't do
this now you're getting there you're in
time because you're in time okay so
that's
so okay the instructive point i made
about the file is still real everybody
but it's just interesting that the move
order is incredibly important that fabi
can go for the end game because of
tactics
like this where you don't defend the
pawn notice that you don't play this
because now white comes up and then
white will get the file and the
advantage will be massive at least
positionally for them
i don't take
i i will play your move king e2 rk8 k2
now that's i can
leave my king in the center i will play
it here
oh wow so if rookie yeah
yes exactly so uh
i want to to play this position you can
still play rook c8 we will exchange
queens
and i don't know what will i do after i
think he's holding because we're gonna
they're blitzing out this line which is
gonna be interesting i can't wait to see
what small subtlety both the players saw
that maybe we did not because i think
the one bad side for bobby is i'll say
this like i don't think we're headed
toward an end game that he'll have any
winning chances like this is going to be
does white have something on the file
here that that maybe fabi missed and
that was kind of my instinct is this
feels very dangerous for black to have
the the disconnected rooks and the file
to belong to dingley wren
or as fobby drawing but this is not a
game where we're going to have a lot of
excitement or chances for black so
one weakness that i can sport at the b5
square so i have this crazy plan of
playing knight b1 knight c3 then and
knight b5
but maybe you can still uh do something
about it by playing knight eight night
g6 you're just in time yeah so something
like this like a lot of positional
movement i love i love you highlighted
just as another instructive thing that
helping players learn to see the forest
through the trees the really subtle
thing miller just pointed out is that
this is an outpost square and sometimes
you have to recognize the weaknesses
before you can recognize how to get
there so amira sees this square and now
she's immediately pointing out ideas
like this which is again a really
important thing to watch out for because
if you imagine putting a white knight on
b5 and a black and a white brook on c6
like that is a stranglehold and
something that dingley wren would
probably be able to take home so
all right well we are going to have a
lot to take home here in round four
let's back up again because we've we've
now officially really looked at all four
games um the bird's eye view will get us
there but before we do
i want to give a real quick shout out
once again to all the first of all shout
out to the chess kid team and the
amazing things going on if you guys
haven't been watching the chess kid
candidates tournament it's pretty
awesome um it's it kicked off yesterday
in the first rest day but all right also
if you're wondering what hiring a coach
for your kids might look like wonder no
longer again we have the american coach
v-day master james canty giving free
lessons on fridays at 6 p.m eastern
every single week chess kid tv is the
place to be
again that rhymed i am on fire today of
course you can follow all you need to
from the chest kit official accounts on
youtube on instagram you see you see
some of their socials right there
subscribe to twitch.tv chess kid also to
get alerts when they go live so
all right
like we said
four games are underway here that's such
actually such a great uh opportunity to
have a trainer a coach yeah yeah yeah i
we we think it's pretty cool and uh and
uh yeah i mean there's a lot of people
interacting and james of course is
awesome and entertaining so all right
well we're gonna we're gonna back up
here leave you guys and gals with the
bird's eye view
uh to uh to take you home here's a great
look of young christoph duda when we
return it's more live from madrid
round four of the 2022 feed day
candidates is just getting underway
the beautiful chess garden will take you
out and we will see you on the other
side of this short break
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing but chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kit helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more try it for yourself at
chess.com events
i was told by the locals of a chess
school and there's people out there we
should go we should go while they're
opening the door for us let's go let's
go school of chess don't cost nothing
dodging traffic
a game as old as chess itself
and half as dangerous
this is the most dangerous part of our
career
game on gotta give the people what they
want game one keep going don't stop
so we tell them that chess education
gives you better life decisions as we
get hit by a car crossing the road in a
non-crosswalk
at 5 20.
5 20 what time we got
start
dude
stay and crash of all the places we
could film in spain the fact there's
going to be a class and we're here
we can film other stuff but we got to
stay for that yeah i agree people say
crashing weddings is fun we're crushing
a school
if the chest is not taking place
check it out
flamenco dancing huh you think of what
i'm thinking you want to be my partner
are there partners in flamenco we're not
even graffitiing a building we're like
trying to help local kids and yet
somehow i see this going poorly
this would be like you know
being at the public courts and like
federer comes
we are walking quickly i heard the word
sigiridad and i was like no security god
might leave you not yeah
the police knob but we gotta go
you know they obviously kind of knew
that we were
you know we kind of knew we were a big
deal they opened up their arms and so
this is why when we were kids our dad
told us to say open sesame yeah which
gets you into the building but if you
say open ahadres you do not get in you
don't go to the village no no it's open
sesame you got to remember that dad was
right i play a lot of it yeah i love it
you could have gotten us into the
building do you play on chess.com yes of
course do you know who that is uh no
you don't need to no you just need to
use the app he's the face of chess.com
do you have a diamond membership no
that's like the paid membership yeah no
i'll give it to you
seriously yeah for now you get a
peccatina there you go
so just
next time you're on the site just send a
message to support and say i met danny
in spain say i met danny and danny said
he would i could get a diamond
membership okay all right i love your
work
i love your work thanks bye-bye so it's
funny danny we were sold a bill of goods
they flew us here to do real work yeah
and i realized our entire job is just to
go around getting out of the stickers
honestly let's oh well there you go i
can't even do that well
[Music]
the amazing scene that was the opening
ceremony at the four seasons here in
madrid
you were there right
yes
[Music]
one of the highlights
like i said it saved me a trip now i
don't even worry
[Music]
shout out to our partners for putting on
a great great opening ceremony there and
uh shout out to everybody who's with us
if you're just tuning in where have you
been
your mom has been calling
she wants you to watch chess
um
and uh we've got a we've got we've got a
great day ahead of us four interesting
games
well i've been told that people are
watching us while working you know
they're watching while working the
numbers would say that they probably are
um if your boss comes by just like make
sure you have a spreadsheet to pull up
you know exactly like something so you
look like you're something you need the
perfect alibi you know perfect alibi
just a bunch of tabs open
right uh easy to toggle back and forth
um okay but
we are going to be toggling to this game
a lot almira because it's
it's to me the most exciting so far
we uh
we're gonna have a lot of interesting
tactics to talk about ever since purusha
played this thematic
moved d5 in the center and then we saw
yon de palma she respond with a pawn
sacrifice of his own if you're looking
at the upper right diagram there's a
reason the black king has been blown
open it's because yonder palmishi has
sacrificed upon
giving the young man from france here
something to think about
elmira i i understand though you uh when
we first saw the d5 push you had a bit
of a story you wanted to tell
about that oh yes of course no that's
like i'm trying to link different uh
historical moments and
since those sacrifices were well were so
natural for tell i remember that
uh when he played his well that
candidates were not always played in
this format so there were matches
tournaments so they switched in i think
in 1965 to matches and then at some
point tal had to face ben larson and
their score was tied so and they had to
play the last game and it was one of the
craziest sicilians once again that you
could have seen and of course tell
sacrifice like ferruccio played d5 here
with black but of course it was so easy
for tal to sacrifice the knight on d5
and it was a very beautiful game
tal won it and he won the match so
and we know that's uh
well what happened later of course we'll
see if we'll see if you're prophetic and
that maybe whoever wins this game goes
on to win the candidates right i mean
okay it's not out of the question that
either of these two
are potentially capable of winning the
event yana panbashi the last winner of
the candidates co-leader with fabio
carwana ali raza perugia the
the talk of the town as they say um for
many people
this this game is not going to
disappoint let's let's again just talk
about the the craziness we see here
right we we've seen knight to g3 by the
way we were right knight df6 was the
right move you had to keep this pony
guarding the g7 square in view of bishop
h6 and all kinds of g-file nastiness
but after knight df6 yonda pomnishi
quickly responded with knight to g3
and ali reza ferruccia has been on the
clock for count it 18 minutes and 25
seconds look at that
by the way shout out to the team with
the move time or the move number for
especially our more most experienced
over-the-board chess viewers
the move number is critical because
remember you have to reach move 40 in
order to get more time on the clock so
we will we will continue to talk about
especially as we move into hour three
that's when you really look at the the
context of where the players stand on
the timer what move number they're at
before reaching move 40 and we start to
see some extra drama
and well there was one other point that
i wanted to talk about is that
when there is so much at stake why i
wanted to tell this story
tell stay true to himself
both players are in this game as well so
we see a very complicated battle and
that's what even that was so much
pressure you know that every move can be
fatal fatal so they are still playing uh
in their style they're in their element
and this game is going to be once again
very wild
i love that point elmira it's it's
poetic right it's like even with
everything on the line you play your
game right you don't change your style
because of what's at stake right you
have to trust what got you there and i
mean okay perugia has been has been
saying that you know he doesn't feel the
pressure no matter what carlson says no
matter what anybody says alireza's like
yo i'm 19 as of like a day ago i play
chess for a living how cool is that
right like he's like he's like i'm cool
and yonda pandashi i really feel again
that funny storyline how many people
even even our own profile with don
anderson by the way shout out john
amazing job on those
is that the expectations seem to be
lower for yon right but he doesn't feel
that way jan has more experience now
than he's ever had you know and he's
also staying true to his aggressive
style he's going for a win against this
kid today as white
and yes while elias is still thinking
you know he's uh while facing a lot of
threats in this position once again we
uh we were talking about knight f5 rook
g1 um bishop h6
um
by the way we have a little more context
if we go to the analysis board so we can
add some variations here maybe
apparently the first really official
move
was right here
the g takes f so so every everything as
we said bishop c4 was the first less
popular move than a4 from perugia but as
elmira said it's logical we're getting
main lines one thematic breakthrough i'm
willing to sack the house to get attacks
yonda pandashi responds with it but in
this position the move that has been
played was knight to g3 first so like an
inner meso right you you free the f5
square and this is the move that have
been played before
g takes f6
apparently has only been played in a few
correspondence games but never
never in over-the-board high-level chess
and that that could be scary for for
ferruccia if yonda pombashi has jumped
into some correspondence analysis that's
where you find some real novelty chances
exactly that's what i wanted to say
these
this correspondence database which
professional chess players
have to consult every time they prepare
their well for their games is is a very
scary database you know it's like you if
this game uh
uh was um
trusted by jan's team
it means that this is probably the line
which is given by uh yeah by by the
computers at the very deep level
which means we could be seeing very very
deep prep in a game like this for those
who don't speak
uh fluent chess terminology
correspondence chess is as it sounds
right now now you can play daily chess
on chess.com where you have maybe three
or seven days a move but correspondence
chess historically was played over over
literally male right they would they
would send letters to each other and
before before the dawn of computers
correspondence players were playing
maybe the highest level chess it wasn't
it wasn't as revered as over-the-board
chess but a lot of great novelties came
from players who had weeks to analyze a
move right and so
if you're if you're playing a move that
has only been seen in correspondence
games
um
you're probably playing something as
elmira said that your team of seconds
trusts that has been checked by
computers
it's it's an only it's a subtle move
order right now
it's very similar to the move that have
been played before but what will the
differences be of taking first and then
knight g3
well we're gonna find out um first of
all they're i want what i want to say
they're playing in
like
in the style of the renaissance masters
it's a it's a very romantic game you
know a lot of sacrifices
knight g3 um
well what is the difference first
because uh you can always take on g5
you know they should if you don't play
knight g3 first but you leave the uh the
pawn on g5
this gives you this option
so you want to take on no no just before
just to explain so maybe that was a
possibility because for me like here if
six
g takes f6
when you no no f6g takes f6 if knight g3
you can take on g5
you see so
you you should definitely consider this
option as well
maybe it's losing but uh
oh there's bishop c4 and queen d7 now i
saw it so you cannot play this
you see you're losing in one i'm sorry
i'm looking at the position yeah it's
no it now it's uh it's a very it's very
trivial so you cannot take on g5
so that's the threat after an ig3 as
well you want uh in the live game it's
the threat in the current position too
that no now like that's why the knight
on d7 is god
so he took knight knight f6 so it's it's
very important also to take with the g7
knight yep okay
yup okay um
well
farruga has his uh
his work cut out for him um but he's
been
he's been making a lot of people work in
the chess world for the last couple
years on his way up the rankings
breaking records along the way
let's remind everybody of just how big
and bright this kid's future is with our
chess.com player highlight
considered by most as the rising
superstar in chess alireza faruja makes
his candidates debut here in madrid
the only teenager in the tournament
ferruja is the youngest player ever to
break the 2800 rating barrier
born in iran but representing france
farouza strikes fear in his opponents
with his array of surprising tactical
shots
alireza qualified for the candidates by
taking first place in the fide grand
swiss he also followed up that
performance with a strong finish at the
european team chess championship
coming in with heavy expectations
farouza has a more than reasonable
opportunity here to become the youngest
winner in candidates tournament history
with that the teen prodigy would take
one step closer to potentially knocking
magnus carlsen off his championship
perch
you know one of the comments there from
donya really caught my attention even
though i've i've seen the profile a few
times
we've highlighted that ali reza perugia
is the third youngest player to be in
the candidates both carlson and fischer
got there earlier
but they didn't win it on their first
time so if he is to win the candidates
he will be the youngest player ever to
win the candidates and right now
with a very solid start especially given
that he had two blacks
he uh he might be on his way to doing so
elmira well that's a very important
observation because
we all know how many attempts fisher had
before winning the candidates and how
difficult it is to win this tournament
so uh
you're absolutely right yeah it could be
the panda she of course is his opponent
today depending on how that goes we'll
see we'll see what he can come up with
with due to karwana and ding and i think
the thing we have to highlight about the
three days remaining after the battle
with napalmashi today is the kid finally
starts to get some whites right he gets
white in around five and then a second
white in a row in round six
uh before getting black um as we prepare
for the back half of the event it's just
important right at this level not to say
you can't get winning chances as black
but it often takes some cooperation
maybe some overpressing uh some some
sort of missed line or maybe maybe they
guessed wrong about what you were going
to do most the time these players are
getting their ws when they have the
first move so it'll be interesting to
see what he can do when he gets when he
gets the white pieces
especially it's like when you're
preparing with black pieces you're
saying oh no this again you know like
how to equalize and this opening uh well
our
viewers of course already know how
difficult it is to uh well to play with
black at this high level but how many
openings you have to overview before the
game so hard
these guys make it look easy you know
top players make it look easy to
remember all the things that they're
doing but okay
um
anyway right now he he i don't think
he's trying to remember anything elmira
i think he's trying to figure this out
because it's jan who has struck first
sort of returning the favor of what
farouza did to hikaru on sunday before
the rest day right where it was for ruja
who surprised takara here it is
definitely napalmashi who has brought a
little more firepower to the table
these positions of course relatively the
ideas will be known but but he really
doesn't want to misstep here because you
can blunder away the game at any moment
in a sharp position and can we have a
look at the very natural move which come
up to my mind like i'm so afraid of like
of what's going on yeah so i want to
play king chait okay or just
king safe it is very important
so uh just what's going on in this
position because one of the
ideas behind knight three was of course
to take the bishop on c4 but now that we
know that we're no longer yeah because
the queen's losing the knight on d7 so
if
takes takes black is fine because the
rook and bishop defend the queen i think
you're more likely to see white
keep the tension whether it's taking
here or even just play moves like rook
g1 and just kind of slowly get the
pieces in a position where some tactics
could go wrong for black i kind of like
this move though uh sorry after after
king h8
e takes d5
i don't know why i like it but i kind of
feel like
this is just the type of position i
expect elmira we're like
just keeping the pressure white is down
a pawn but here comes knight f5 here
comes bishop h6 the longer you let the
engine think here it's going to get back
close to equality and white's pressure
is just going to continue to mount right
and with an open g file
it's just
the reason i'm liking john's chances
more and more is because from a
practical perspective this position is
going to be so much easier for white to
play
blacks black's missteps are potentially
fatal whereas white's missteps
okay i mean at this level anyone can
blow but you get what i'm saying right
this is going to be a very dangerous
position for ferruccia
it reminds me also of the game that hyun
played with white pieces against fabian
quran in this tournament once again you
know he sacrificed the pawn
for a long-term initiative and even
though that the computer didn't like his
position uh from once again from a human
perspective
it is always difficult to defend those
positions
but i really think that king h8 here is
uh
is well
necessary
yes it's a it's a prophylactic move
get the king out of danger before you
even have to deal with the rook on the g
file wouldn't be surprised if we see it
um
again it's hard to make other moves
maybe we should spend some more time
pointing out basic tactics we want to
make sure everyone knows i mean you
can't really do anything with the d-pawn
without this guy hanging
you don't want to take here because
white will take with just a natural rook
actually you could take with either one
to be honest but
i i was about to take with this one but
then i was like maybe i want the default
wow wait alireza has taken on f1
and the computer likes it a little more
for white
i wonder which rook it is
i think that he wants to use this moment
to
oh to push his pawns maybe that's why he
took on f1
well d4 maybe b3 a3 like he needs to do
something fast yeah
so uh a3 maybe because b3 is given it
give it all right what do you think
but i mean i guess you know white's
going to keep this closed and to me what
i what i'm looking at again once again
but still like i'm looking at the it's
more position i'll approach knight g6
knight b5 knight knight c3 you know but
this is way too slow probably in a
position where like you cannot lose the
tempe yeah
no it's likely true and if you're taking
now like i'm guessing things like queen
g2 or just something something that
attacks the queen threatens to move the
knight
and also white's king is
is relatively safe there because like
you need to uh to be to bring your queen
and your bishop on the dark square yeah
yep the queen and the bishop
coming in and the point is it would be
it's hard for
although maybe maybe this is is actually
risky because at some point
black will have ideas like you're
pointing out so perhaps white would
maybe even trade here and go bishop c5
in some positions but okay just to set
the stage
making sure we're pointing out all the
opportunities to go wrong this is this
is a
it's a weird trade to me for black
because
these are the positions where white's
job is just getting easier i'm going to
take back either way i'm going to put my
knight on f5 i'm going to start to bring
pieces over to this side of the board
and i don't think black is mustering up
anything nearly as dangerous against
white as what napon rishi is going to
have on the g file
um
so
browsers let's take on f1
okay take
yes something we need to take and then
i almost did it but the more the more i
look at it more i actually want the rook
on this file i think that's important
of course so we we can try b3 or let's
try b3
sacrifice and sacrifice and so i will
take
i like maybe i'll just take it i'll just
take it all
something like
d4
now
bishop h6 and we are completely lost
probably here
knight to 5 is coming yes i don't like
this at all no no no this is
yeah this is
super scary i mean
again elmira's playing in the spirit of
what we said earlier if you've been with
us that pawns are less important than
the initiative and positions with kings
on the opposite sides of the board
i say that loosely obviously pawns
matter but the point is that sacrificing
material is very common when you have an
attack
but black has no way
black would love to just take all four
of these pawns off the board
in order to meet meet the pressure that
white has but black can't just do that
a3 will be met by b3 most likely
and again it's only a matter of time
before these types of things start
happening
and black's king comes under serious
firepower so
if i'm if i'm a furuga fan
i'm a little nervous in this game
i was thinking about a
an exchange also for black like whenever
you will play bishop h6 i will simply
leave my room there yes give the rook
maybe something like um
you play like here or something yes
queen c7 and if i go here and i want to
bring i desperately want to bring
my knight on the eight into play but uh
yeah you'd love to put the knight on the
c3 but you're checking but you're so
funny can i play knight d6 here or it's
to today i have checkmate ah queen g5 of
course so you see when i start
blundering that means that the position
is very dangerous like
i cannot i cannot see all the threads
here yeah no this is some bishop we see
yawn did capture back with this rook
agrees that the defile is the place to
be
oh man this is we're going to keep an
eye on this one because
we could we could be getting in some
very dangerous territory quickly we'll
see if furuja has an idea that
that we haven't discussed yet but i'm
yeah i was right about king hate you
know this doesn't matter
instead of missing one yes
so
all right let's let's back up to the
bird's eye view again and remind
everybody of where the other three games
sit uh
interesting that dingley ren did not
choose to execute pressure along the c
file instead shuffled the queen to b3
i think i think
due to rajabov will uh
will give us some interesting maneuvers
long term a bit of a closed position
there
and then you have rapport nakamura
i guess first meets the eye you call it
a boring position kind of a berlin end
game that wasn't really a berlin
but still
a very equal and tame looking position
over there
it's funny though hey karu ikaru is very
dangerous in these positions long term
they're dead equal
objectively should probably just be a
draw if both players play well according
to the computers he's played these
berlin end games right so many times and
and maybe in like just ten thousand
online games alone let alone like the
games that people you know remember
battles against players like maxine
basha the grav or whatever so i give i
give hikaru always practical chances
openly acknowledging hikaru bias itis
over here um because i've just i've seen
him do it too many times so we'll see
how that game goes objectively should
should be kind of a tame one though
well but he has one psychological button
so you know he's playing black don't
forget it so that's sure even if he
draws that's not a bad result and once
again you well if richard didn't get
anything out of the opening that means
that he's sitting there looking at this
end game and let's say okay maybe this
is a draw and this is
when hikaru can see well the opportunity
and to play for a win actually because
you're just not feeling well about the
position with white okay what can i get
yeah
because very often i
what i see is that the players do not
switch the gears and hikaru does your
car knows how to switch gears that's a
great that's a great way to put it
sometimes you're you're okay with the
draw beforehand of course and whenever
you give them chests it's okay maybe if
it's slight chance maybe even if i play
for two hours it's it will still be a
draw but hikaru switches gears perfectly
yeah
i think i think carlson is another
person who we know switches gears but i
i agree i think that's a good
observation of one of the things that
hicarro does really well is
you come in with a plan as the old
saying goes you come with a plan until
you get hit right at the uh whatever the
is that a mike tyson quote everyone has
a plan or is it
no i i get well known this one
but but sometimes everyone has a plan
and
certain players who just psychologically
were okay with a draw they don't push
when given the chance right and if you
have a chance to hit right hikar hikaru
is someone who doesn't miss it so
um
but honestly though just looking at the
chess on the board the game i'd like to
dive into next is dude over a job off
when we when we when we have a chance to
do that because
the truth is i don't think we're going
to see anything concrete in the report
nakamura game for a minute but i want to
see how they got that structure where
rajab has willingly taken on the double
pawns
and uh
and now has played rook to g8
trying to kind of
flip the script here on the king side
let's let's back up to where we left it
because we said how dangerous this
position was almira after knight c3
bishop d7 was played
and he did in castle yeah first of all
yes of course this
knight a4 going for the bishop pair
rajabov says no thank you i will save my
bishop even at the cost of losing a ton
of time that's an interesting decision
to save the bishop losing all of this
time feels
that feels risky to me no but sort of
like if you switch the colors and
if
black could do the same you'd play like
in in the spanish show when you play a6
b5 knight h5 so it's the same procedure
actually so yeah if you're allowed to do
so you always go for this you know i get
scared about pawn storms
only two things in life that scare me
more than pawn storms
um
b4
apparently not a big of a deal almira
calms my fears castles for duda
and then knight e7 is the choice that
rajava takes
and that's how we got the double pawns
okay now it all makes sense it's
interesting because i guess what black
is saying as we see the live position
uh you know you're looking at both the
analysis and the live
rajaba plans to put that king on the
queen side and so this is really the
move that that he committed to that idea
with because once you allow bishop takes
f6 and double pawns you're more than
likely not castling short here
so after the bishops get traded you've
opened up the chance to put the king on
the queen side and we've quickly caught
up to the live game
but it came with a positional price
elmira i mean if you were just to take
some pieces off the board here white's
almost winning in an end game because of
just how bad these pawns are if this
king can make a journey up the board
you've got long-term chances all over
the place well well here i i
i disagree a little bit because this
position becomes very concrete and these
ideas you also find in the four nights
opening where
black plays 97 doubles uh the balance
and then and then pushes the five right
right as you said concrete i was in my
head i was like ah this is the key this
is exactly the same because
if you if you can play a five of course
then it means that uh well you're right
in time and you have enough compensation
here for sure
and
especially if you can combine f5 with
even getting the king of the center you
might take and then play a five again
and just continue to open up things on
this side of the board
[Music]
king h1 was played
i guess the i guess the threat was
potentially queen h3 in some awkward
positions because the pawn was pinned
because i was wondering if there was
some chances to do something like queen
h5
queen h5 immediately
well
it's it's probably just terrible but
i've and i and i saw queen h3 so i was
wondering if that was why but let's just
play it
we have an analysis board oh the
knight's hanging lol oh you see you
start blundering
because i was also looking at this i was
so obsessed with the positional idea i
wanted to clamp down this side of the
board right
and and now it means why both queen h5
and queen f3 don't work because both of
them clamp down but both of them blunder
the knight i wanted to tell you that
maybe you could start with a knight b6
first is it possible
okay so you take yes and then play
knight
queen h5 or or even queen f3
one of these
one of this what i wanted to show is
that after queen h3 just yeah this this
is the problem let's say make a random
move yeah i know you're threatening i'll
let you play it go ahead
just wanted to show it so rook g2 is the
threat of course so and the knight is
pinned to the queen
so
uh
in fact even if you play king h1 still
rook takes g2 and you're still
threatening checkmate and the knight is
still pinned to the queen so that's why
if now we're trying to unpack mysterious
king moves that's why duda played king
h1 to get the queen
off of threatening h3 but but i'm not i
don't think i'm totally wrong about this
idea right if if it wasn't for the night
which i blundered right openly admitting
then this idea is coming right you're
trying to put the queen on these squares
you're trying to maybe clamp down to
prevent black from fixing these ugly
ducklings of pawns over here but
that's actually the the feeling that you
get you don't like
f5 you know coming you're starting to
look for the solutions queen of three is
the first one queen h5 is the second one
both
exactly so uh
that's how it goes
so he should play five oh he did
he doesn't play at five i'm actually
oh that's a very interesting
one so
just to make sure that we look at a five
i i think
almera and the computer were both right
that f5 was objectively maybe and it's
the the you know it's the theme of the
day right you've got double pawns the
whole reason this line is is playable
for black is despite how weak they are
the concrete reality is that you can't
stop f5 as i just learned all my moves
were blunders right but he doesn't go
for it
so the question is is there some chances
now to take
take
and
i would play a4 immediately oh just a4
yes here we in by the way how many
opposite sides castling games do we have
today i love this this is chess
this is my kind of chess right here
kings on opposite sides of the board
let's go
but maybe a4 allows f5 okay let's see
it's let's do it it's serious we got to
do
takes takes
takes takes a5 here we go
let's go
open up this side of the board for an
attack
let's take on if just to see how uh
i think how fast it can make it oh you
want to take with the box i think so i
think that maybe that's even better
and then queen b3
these sort of things this is
i'm i'm glad my instincts were correct
to choose this game next because i
really believe that we're we're going to
get we're going to get some exciting
chess in this game believe it or not
may i show an idea in that position just
in case if you are opening all files for
example let's just let's get to our
position which we analyzed very quickly
just in case so
i think that here if you take let's see
take
and you were mentioning queen bit three
as soon as you're leaving you know
from d one i can take on g two rook g2
and you're losing because they have
queen g4 queen of three rook g let's
show that so like you have to be careful
let's say like you're just i'm just
gonna make a move like d5 is a move
right and the moment you try to start
bringing pieces to this side of the
board for an attack
you neglect a king with no help
and black immediately executes a mating
net
on this side of the board so even in the
position which might look very simple
here and equal
uh
there are a lot of uh tactical ideas yes
i love positions like that because i
think you just you you said it well
right even a position that looks like
look there's no minor pieces on the
board here there's no tactics here
what's going on but
guess again right you have to watch out
anytime your king has no minor pieces
protecting it sacrifices are in the air
because at the highest goal of we ranked
our pyramid in chess
checkmate's at the top doesn't matter
how much pieces you had to sacrifice to
get there if you can checkmate your
opponent you win the game and it's
actually a very interesting feeling
because that's what i how did i uh come
up with this work gentoo because i feel
relieved okay no more nights on the
board you know that's like and during
the game i feel exactly the same okay
you can breathe let's have a look how
can i mate my opponent yeah i like it
and then you miss rob jitu
yeah
all right well
interesting stuff here let's uh we'll
see how rajava captures back i'm sure
it'll be a takes b6 and we'll we'll
likely get our
our position we were talking about but
looking at all four games here
remind everybody of uh
where each position stands ali reza
faruga is still on the clock against
yonda pomneshi
yeah i've got a bad feeling for farouza
in that game so it's going to take some
defense
and this is
this is not end game defense this is uh
this is run for your life defense
checkmate right sometimes it's more fun
you know um
but uh but that's going to be a tricky
one
as we said report to nakamura in an end
game and we were just at deuteros
going on over there
let's have a look at
the long-term positional torture yeah i
was going to say this game was a
potential rabbit hole to go down because
all i want to do here is like give
myself a selfish chess lesson and just
analyze why didn't they go for this so
i'm going to avoid that and just kind of
look at the live position
but
i want to understand why there wasn't
more there for
oh
i cannot take the phone
rook c8 and queen b6 yes
uh
was it played on the board
rook c8 was played on the board it's
it's right there right
so rook c8 quincy queen b6 let's make it
like queen c2 maybe
that is fabi's plan but
queen a5 and i protect
the knight as well
could this be blunder
the eval bar says it likes white i mean
all right
we're gonna dive into all that this move
is and figure out whether it's a blunder
or not but i bet dingley wren is going
to be checking variations for a minute
so but while he's on the clock
we're going to we're going to remind
everybody of why the hype from this for
this guy is so real more than a million
people are tuning in daily from china i
saw that stat from fidei
this guy has
an entire nation behind him and a lot of
people's high expectations
for his uh his what would look like a
match between him and magnus carlson so
let's learn a little bit more about
dingley wren in our latest chess.com
player profile
it took some good fortune but dingley
wren arrives at the candidates with some
very legitimate reasons to think he can
secure a bid to challenge for the world
title for the very first time
a visa issue originally kept ding out of
the last opportunity to qualify
but when a spot opened ding was next man
up based upon his hot streak of late
the timing couldn't be better for ding
an entertaining and unpredictable player
ding enters the candidates rated higher
than any player in the field
the chat went nuts they love their man
daily run we said this is an engine move
humans don't find it and he found king
of one i am absolutely stunned once
again this is such a difficult move
the strongest player in china's history
ding is the only player from that
country to earn a 2800 rating
launched by an undefeated streak across
100 straight classical games ding has
sat amongst the world's top five for the
past five years
once out of the tournament completely
ding now aims to bring china into a
world chess championship match for the
first time in his native land's history
dingley wren
has so so many interesting storylines i
mean we can talk about how he got here i
mean donja did such a good job
summarizing uh what a wild ride that was
before we do that let's just talk about
what he
what he faced in the first few rounds
because he started out with a loss right
despite all the pressure and all the
expectations and everything he did to
get here how do you recover from losing
with white in the first round of the
candidates elmira
well you you make a draw first you make
your jaw so you stop the bleeding you
stop the bleeding and well yesterday's
game was not um
uh
well
true to his style because i think he was
completely winning with white of course
yeah i guess report yeah against reports
so i think he's still looking for his
form because he arrived i think uh quite
late yeah so he
he didn't have enough time to adjust as
other candidates did and he's also alone
here so he's supported as you said by
the whole country is
supporting him but here he is alone
we see him play rook take c8 we'll see
if he grabs the pawn on v6 but let's
let's stay on that because
he arrived late
and also
maybe maybe all those pressures of of
how he qualified he had to play this 30
games in may right the the crazy
expectations on him
if he finds his form and let's say maybe
even gets a win against fabiano right
this is the kind of guy who i could see
just getting better as the tournament
goes on right he arrived late maybe
tired right tons of expectations right
exhausted from the journey but if he
finds his form nobody's going to be
happy with who dingley rim becomes on
the back half of this event
once again he hasn't played a high level
i mean over the board chess for quite a
while so
he uh he still wants he's adjusting
himself and also you are completely
right this is a tournament uh which
lasts
well for 14 rounds we're going to be in
madrid for a while
and uh well he
if he wins this game today he's
certainly going to um
to tune you know
how do you
tune your cars you know to to be faster
he'd also be i i did my predictions in
very quick fashion admittedly so maybe
that was good because i was worried we
really wanted to catch the the players
before they started so i jumped in gave
the command for everyone to go vote
hopefully you're playing a long chat
but i predicted dingley run to win this
game and young machine to win his game
okay what a shake-up that would be if
one of the co-leaders goes down to his
you know in some ways nemesis at the top
level fabiano has not done well with
black against dingley wren
um
and if yonda palmer she gets a win over
there against varusia but
but yeah i
this this is going to be a tough
position for fabian holding especially
against a player as technical and as
precise as dingley run
but you were given also the official
numbers and i was um curious
uh
because nowadays we we have the same
numbers of viewers watching hikaru
so millions watching hikaru she has
it's a novelty yeah
it's
yes he has a lot of support
behind him china is looking to have to
have someone in a world chess
championship match um
they've had many of the best players in
the world in the in the women's
side of things competing you think of
hoey fawn you think of human june you
think of some just household names
dominating women's chess for the last
decade or so
but they'd love to see someone competing
for the world chess championship against
carlson and dingley wren is the best
chance they've they've ever had last
candidate's tournament
they were represented by two players
dingle wren and van gaal
so i think that was also a first
and ding is
trying it once again
yep okay fabiano went for a4 not the
immediate queen c2
that was the plan
this is a huge decision from caruana
to sacrifice that pawn
active defense active defense he doesn't
want to hold this position uh passively
even though it's probably uh
well
easy to hold it i don't know but uh once
again from the human perspective
well do you want to be tortured for 100
moves
yeah i don't want to be tortured for 100
moves um that was a trick question did i
pass
okay i i don't want to be tortured for
under moves so now i know what opening
choices i will have against you i yeah
open sicilians that's what i want
sharpshooters no i'm always like bishop
v5 yeah exactly um
okay let's let's analyze this a little
bit because
it's um
it's a move that
the computers aren't thrilled about when
black plays the move rook to c8
but perhaps there's just some really
deep feel bobby has for black's drawing
chances here because you're you're going
in for a force line that gives up a pawn
and digly ren has has accepted this
offering
and after a4 what you're saying is look
i'm down a pawn
but this one pawn
is actually holding back both of white's
pawns we got our first ombasant meme of
the day to remind everybody that if you
play b4
uh well first of all if you played
before right away black is actually
bringing the queen into one of these
squares but i'm just showing on passant
the idea is that this pawn holds back
both of the pawns because of the rule of
ompassant so so if you take pieces off
the board
one pawn can actually hold back two
pawns in scenarios like this and this is
very basic so apologies for those who
know that but it's an important rule
because this is a poem we call a
backward pawn right almira a backward
pawn is a pawn on an open file that
can't push because it'll be captured
either one or two squares
and um that allows fabi to have multiple
threats here including queen c2
including queen to b8 if the pieces come
off the board
maybe black is like look yeah i'm down a
pawn but
but i'm actually holding on just fine
yes and look at this knight not only
he's fixing the structure but the knight
on g2 doesn't have too many squares now
because the b3 was a very important
square to take away from this knight
because we had this maneuver of knight
b3 knight c5 supporting the a pound in
the long term yeah that would have been
good but you can't get there right now
so probably
the knight on f6 is even a better night
given the long-term perspective but
let's see a4
uh dink has to do something about this
immediately
i think he's otherwise
either queen to b4 or even
i said b4 wasn't possible and i was i
was trying to highlight the educational
point of on poisson but i think b3 is
more interesting and the big reason is
that now if you play queen to c3 i can
play queen b4
and offer uh
an exchange
and if i play queen c2 first queen
before as well yes so i i guess i guess
it's probably the best yeah and if i
bring can i bring my rook into play now
because that's the only um piece you
know yes okay torx c8
now rook city will probably take on a4
but if you simply take here
i wish i could take with the rook
for the moment you you will have to
exchange the queens and maybe
to hold this position yeah
how is this if you let's see queen a4
takes or rook b1 i think rook b1 is also
interesting or
you could go to either of these squares
actually because of the back rank
problems that black faces but just to
show the idea like if you go here
let's say black
you know frees the back rank in some way
or another
how is white making progress
when
black's pieces are just perfectly placed
here right that's kind of bobby's point
is
the computer says white's better but
he's like look yeah you can have this
eval all you want you can have this evil
to the end of the game but it might
still be a draw because you're up a pawn
which is why the computer likes white
but but how do you use that pawn another
question but okay let's take on a4 rook
a4 rugby three i need to protect and i
will use my knight b1 knight c3 of
course one day so
uh so i want to get my night over
do i also want to just
and run here
well if you run here then that's my
point i will give up the iphone but i
will certainly start checking you and uh
rook b7 and
going for the pawns on the seventh rank
yeah i like it
so it's not so easy to defend this
knight one first i think and
even knight two three
here and if you go back to the seventh
rank i push eight fours okay so this is
this is going to be ding ding's plan
right so
fabi has sacrificed the pawn
as you see the live position
the queens are still on the board but
this type of variation on the left is is
is quite probable i think in a game like
this black has to figure out a way to
stop
white from using that extra pawn but you
can use the same maneuver like improve
your knight by playing knight e8 knight
d6 and then knight c4 also so yeah so
like something like this
and now if you play a5 i have knight c4
so this is it's going to be tricky
if avi already has some sort of just
intuitive knowledge or maybe he's looked
at this type of end game before and
feels confident in his ability to hold
it then that would be that would be
quite impressive i guess you know just
from the perspective that
it looks so scary to us human players
um you know
we're not we're mere mortals compared to
the gods before you and dingley ren and
fabiano caruana
giving up a pawn like this but
but maybe black can hold this again
i say we as in the royal we i'm talking
about myself maybe you're not you know
i'm immortal but
um
and i noticed that i was trying yes to
uh
to find out the way
well to to continue because okay now
all our pieces are in optim on optimal
squares for white and black so now you
have to continue so are you playing
something like f3 g4 h4
yeah
principle of two weaknesses once again
so you need to open the second front yep
i like f3 i even like h4 or g4 right
away
because once again you have to sit and
wait yep you have to be patient and
and again
to show some instructive stuff for
viewers like when we when we say these
moves like h4 and g4 like what are you
actually threatening when the position
is completely symmetrical but let me
just like paint a picture real quick to
show
what would happen if nothing occurs in
this game and you do eventually get
these types of majorities and remember
you'll you'll have improved your king
somewhere that that's not the point
even in a completely symmetrical
structure if you have more space which
means your pawns are further advanced up
the board there's always the chance for
some tension because you have this
long-term goal in nhs game which is to
queen upon so in a position like this if
you're eventually threatening a move
like g5 again the computer's not going
to like it forget that if you take it
you're giving me an outside pass pawn
if you refuse to take it i can take it
and now i have an isolated pond which
long term is a weakness and target for
my knight sometimes you know this king
is on a different square and you're
threatening to take not even just
because the pawn but maybe to get an
open file for your rook and so these are
just a couple examples of the type of
things you're threatening when you have
even in a symmetrical structure
when you have control over the board and
what i mean by that is your opponent's
pieces are stuck to this side because if
they get too jiggy with it and start
getting fancy over here well you're
going to push your pawn and you're going
to win at some point with the extra
material so that when we say principle
two weaknesses that's why this is sort
of a tail as old as soviet chess right
it's it's about massaging the the
advantage don't beat your head against a
wall if your opponent has proven a
blockade and you can't push because
they're going to stop it then don't do
anything leave it be and look to support
expansion and weaknesses on the other
side of the board you often see amateurs
on mirror miss play end games precisely
because they get so obsessed with one
idea
you know their one advantage that they
forget part of the problem with being
worse in a position everybody
is that you have nothing to do and your
opponent can torture you so you have to
look for these principles of two
weaknesses ideas and hopefully that's
something to kind of
you know take away and learn from an
endgame like this in terms of why there
are winning chances even though it looks
sort of tame of course and while doing
so you should also be careful for
example especially in that position that
we've seen when you play f3 you create
one weakness in your own camp this is
the
so you have to prepare it yeah
you have to bring your king then player
3 g4 you have to be very patient yep
that makes sense
so dingley run plays queen b4 first
um
rather than the b3 move we played that
kind of reached that line we had but i
think it's maybe it's just a
it could just be a transposition
on queen to c2 white can still play b3
so it's quite possible
um
but what other moves uh fabiano has at
his disposal here
can he play um
well something artificial i don't know i
i want to to bring my rook into play i
mean fabiano is spoken to play so i need
to
which is why the moves we looked at
queen
c2 okay it's hard to find better moves
because
any other by the way there's a direct
threat in the position we we should
always keep pointing this out white is
threading to win the pawn on a4
so let's not forget queen b4 was played
to win the pawn on a4 so you have to
deal with that which is why the queen
has to find some sort of square and
that's why we looked at then b3 and try
to get the outside past a pawn so
all right well bobby's going to be
thinking here um probably for a minute
really critical that he gets ideal
defensive
uh spots for his pieces if he's going to
hold this game
so while we watch while we watch this
battle
we uh we have some fun to throw to for
those of you who saw uh one of the one
of the videos at the break you might
already have a little teaser of the fact
that mike klein and i fun master mike
caught up caught up with the city of
madrid and bounced around we had some we
had some fun times and so uh we we
actually tried to go to a local chess
school
um let's just say we didn't get in and
uh we'll we'll let you enjoy this
highlight of that trip as we wait for
the next move to be played here
right i play a lot of it yeah i love it
you could have gotten us into the
building you play on chess.com yes of
course do you know who that is
no
you don't need to no you just need to
use the app he's the face of chess.com
do you have a diamond membership no
that's like the paid membership yeah no
i'll give it to you
seriously yeah for now you get a
peccatina there you go
so just
next time you're on the site just send a
message to support and say i met danny
in spain
say i met danny and danny said he i
could get a diamond membership okay all
right i love your work
it's it's fun to be a star when kids
just recognize who you are i just said
that you're not supposed to talk to
kids strangers
madrid were very friendly in fact one
one of the pieces of footage that didn't
make it there is mike was just handing
out stickers to just random little kids
and their parents were totally fine with
it you know not suspicious at all of
anything weird going on i don't know
that i look at fun master mike with a
lot of trust anyway uh jokes aside it
was it was a lot of fun and um we're
gonna be bringing you some more videos
throughout our coverage here in madrid
uh we uh well people play chess here
everywhere
so in parks you know
there is a very long lasting chess
tradition in spain there are so many
tournaments organized so as we can see
that there are no more tickets for the
candidates so well that's why people
love chess here
they do and uh
we we we had very mixed bag like that
was a fun one you know uh kids who use
the app obviously had no idea who we
were which we don't expect that was that
was a joke just so you know we are we
are self-aware everybody uh but we did
have people who were aware of the
candidates and people who were aware
that takara was playing the candidates
that was one of the story lines that
continues to just prove his stardom
because so many people it shouldn't be a
surprise he has a million twitch
followers you know but every time i'm on
the street and someone's like yeah like
a car was playing the candidates i'm
like oh wow okay like it tells you like
people people have been following at
least that particular ride so um
finally finally finally we got there and
then of course they mentioned the other
star beth harmon right the queen's
gambit right she has instantly become
the third or fourth biggest star in the
history of chess so uh let's take a look
at all four games and see where we stand
real quick in our in our bird's eye view
we see that f5 has finally been played
on the board by rajab in that lower left
corner
the napomnishi faruga game is going to
get spicy with alireza committing to a3
and don't be surprised if the game that
we haven't given a lot of attention to
report nakamura at some point offers
interesting chances
it's equal
but uh it's equal but it could be could
be a moment where a player could go
wrong but um
all right i'm here we're gonna we're
gonna take our next um
break uh before we dive into these games
but before we do i want to remind
everybody
that the chess.com global championship
is running
every weekend this is your chance to
play an event that has the world's best
players you can quali right now you're
qualifying your way into the title
player stage and at some point lots of
superstars are joining so you want to do
that all you have to do is go to
go.chest.comcgc2022 to get verified and
sign up uh these qualifiers as we said
are running every saturday and sunday
through july 31st and it's your chance
to compete in the largest event we've
ever held
a million dollars plus in prizes it's
pretty epic so we hope we hope that you
give it a give it a whirl
all right elmira i think when we come
back we'll we'll pay off pay off some
report nakamura because we haven't
looked at that in a long time i know
it's just a rook and night ending but i
think there might be some more
instructive stuff there for the fans um
and then of course we're gonna
maybe circle back to the most exciting
game
which will be napomnishi for russia but
okay there is the man who i said is
recognized in the streets maybe
maybe more than anybody these days
because of the following that he has
grown on twitch and youtube
and when we come back we'll dive into
his battle from the black side versus
richard report as well as all the other
games in round four of the 2022 feed a
candidates from madrid
join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
new zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botez gambits has alexandra botes played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com
insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
[Music]
i figure it's time for me to really
blend in you know dress like a local
i don't
i obviously wear jackets all the time
okay
so
we're ready for the candidates every
local madridian visits the chessboard
on a daily basis i hear they visit and
kind of
pay tribute
to queen isabella herself this is a
i hear that uh
this is
this is a statue of queen isabella
herself
yeah
we are here at the 2022 candidates
tournament in madrid spain and we have
our man on the inside danny wrench who's
been with the players a lot going to the
players meetings and he's here to tell
us about some special requests that a
few of the players made danny what have
they been talking about yeah well
obviously we want to and always ask the
players and get them in the spirit of
the city right the the place that
they're playing from so a couple of
actually kind of unique ones that have
been that have been thrown out there and
i'm going to try to represent these as
well as i can to fit a okay but the
first one was
uh a lot of bonus requests if you play
and win with the spanish on either side
makes sense right makes sense um
there was a uh a suggestion you know
that that anytime you move the queen you
you drop a dab for queen isabella yeah
yeah she's the one that made the queen
power makes sense okay um but then the
players were unanimous on one in
particular which was that every two
hours into every round they'll have a
now if acquired siesta well we'll see if
any of these rules are implemented for
the tournament uh especially if somebody
plays the spanish they got some money
coming their way yeah it doesn't seem
likely but uh i don't even want to know
which players made these requests but
i've got a couple ideas in my mind yeah
well you know and uh if and anything
that gets the players to play something
more than the berlin right the most
exciting draw in the world now that we
have some money on the line perhaps we
see some exciting some exciting spanish
games so i'm i'm actually excited about
that one there you go you need some alex
honold on us
yes
the alex honnold of chess folks climbing
without a rope oh wait i can do it
i don't know why i'm doing this but i
feel like a little kid when i get around
big things slowly checking our insurance
it's like chess parkour
oh did you catch that on camera
can you tell he's a dad of a teenager
[Music]
always move like a night guys i think
i'm gonna go hit a siesta over there
with the uh seems like the thing to do
with the locals you do you baby girl
yeah yeah okay i'll see you guys in a
couple hours
yeah
it's a long day dan you deserve it buddy
you deserve it
go ahead and throw that down and
just
buckle up buddy yeah
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
miss amigos
we have some
flamenco
miss amigos amir have you ever
been in flamenco dancing
no no no never never
have you ever watched a live flamenco
performance yes
yes i do but it's actually it's for me
well it is a form of art
you have to study years of practice in
flamenco just even to try once
i love it
and inside we had dancing at the opening
ceremony there uh as elmira said it is a
form of art we have chess which is also
a form of art being played here inside
the palacio de centonia
but before we get back to the games
elmira let's just
let's welcome everybody again to where
we are we are upstairs here at the
palacio de centonia and what was the
point you were just about to make that
now actually i wanted to ask you a
question if you could compare like our
eight players to musicians or composers
or rock stars who would they be
i think that's a great question maybe we
can ask you get us some featured chat
for sure chad why don't you answer her
question which is if you had to make a
direct comparison of any of our eight
participants people rock star maybe
linking uh this to their way of playing
to their style you know so uh i like
that
yeah so there you go chad let us know
compare them to their style of play
compare them to i mean if you can find
that they look like someone i don't know
like that would be interesting too but
all right
we're uh let's let's take a look at
a a bit of a not not a bird's eye of the
board but a bird's eye of everything we
have in store
um here as far as what's been behind us
and what lies ahead our cross table
tells us who they've played and what
their results have been thus far again
only hikaru has all three different
types of uh of results in his
in his
under his bar if you will a draw a loss
and a win
lots of lots of three draw scores and
then a couple of other players with some
w's napomneshi and caruana so and we
have only three players with the win
only three players with a win anything
else stand out to you about that
well that's very difficult to find first
of all to win a game in this tournament
and uh
uh what do we expect from a winner in
this tournament what's good plus three
score plus four score like i mean in
terms of expectations that's that's a
great question um also a good prediction
for chat honestly maybe that's actually
a direct poll because i'd be curious
what do people think if i had to guess
i think plus three
will be will be good enough um for a
tiger maybe for a and maybe a tiebreaker
um
but okay i mean obviously if someone if
someone is putting up plus four i would
i would bet that
two people will not be capable of that
so plus four would be for sure a win and
so
we look at
we look at all four games in progress
there i think that
yonda pomnishi's game is um
maybe one with becoming winning chances
for both sides but your thoughts on
where to go i know we want to go into uh
report nakamura in a minute but any
anything else stick out to you as we get
a glance remind everybody where all four
games stand
well i do want to have a look at report
nakamura because i think that this end
game is very sharp if you may say this
about an end game so it's about to be
once again to
to become very tactical and if hikaru
manages to play h3 then to fix this
h2 pawn
and then to create some sort of mating
net at the same time it will be very
dangerous for white
yeah i'm uh i'm in agreement elmira that
this is
this is about to get really interesting
and before we even talk about what's
going on over here like is b7 hanging
what's going on with c5 i want to go to
the point elmira just made which is that
h3 is is at some point coming
and regardless again ignoring the engine
right away just showing what you were
saying is that how dangerous this move
is right if you play g3 and now on check
you're just in big shovel because your
only way to to play the position will be
to put the king on h1 otherwise you just
lose the pawn and then we get a queen
but if you play king h1 you're in a
mating net for the rest of the game this
is just
it's a cage
um
and i think that this position is maybe
lost already
yeah because there's
your king is just awake
right i mean you could
you have to deal with the threat so
maybe you bring the knight back to guard
c6 so you can kick and then push but
eventually the the point is once you've
solidified your plan this back rank is
is going to be deadly so
again just looking at the live position
we know that there's some questions to
deal with over here
report has an option to consider taking
this pawn but i i don't think he wants
to to give black another open file in
fact that's a cool thing to show that if
you take and like rook v8 is played
it's actually black who's going to be
better at the end of these lines even
though white's up a pawn because of all
of these back rank problems that we were
talking about h3 is coming the knights
coming in this is this is very very
dangerous and so
that's an interesting point
what else here
well i also think that hikaru wants to
fight for the d file as strange as it
might sound because he wants to play c4
they've given the choice and then maybe
if rook wants to stay on on d4 for
example c5 and then if you take the
panel then after rook d8 you're lost
once again
this is the idea
and if
rook d2 the rook is no longer active
then i can proceed with h3 and knight f3
is coming with a fork so yeah
although it comes from chad said
nakamura is equal to freddie mercury
that's a legendary singer from queen one
of your favorite bands right yes um
i didn't see anything who else bands yet
but we'll keep an eye on you chat um all
right
what else
the
the position is dangerous and report
knows it
maybe it's time to think about uh
bringing the king into play
like king of wood king of one yes
because
i'm a little bit afraid of all these
meeting threats
[Music]
that means that you well you cannot take
these puns you know easily and i'd be
seven knight c5s
it's not an option
well if you don't take them black and
start protecting them i mean maybe maybe
b6 and
eventually i'll go back to the idea of
h3
h3 is a is a really big thorn because
the you know
the exciting thing about h3 is the
mating net we talked about that if h3 if
something like this occurs and the king
is in a mating net this is like
this is devastating but even if that's
not the case the long-term reason h3 is
always a threat is because when you fix
this pawn to h2 you're always in a
position to have tactics and and
especially in end games with a knight
where your opponent will never have a
piece that's great at stopping past
pawns it's very in fact so much so look
at this
rapport is so frustrated by hikaru's
threat of h3 that he says i'm just going
to play h3 myself and take away all this
nonsense it's actually it's a very
interesting turn of events it means like
how uncomfortable he feels about uh this
pawn structure
h2 g3 f2 so h3 is a
it's a very interesting but if you're
taking now on h3 with black yeah he's
going to
so he's going to take
well i wanted to say that
well you can take the bond but you
cannot look let's just show that knight
d4 simply loses to rookie 3 and f3 wait
wait oh no just just in case
and f3
okay and you win the piece
so um
no knight e4
but let's maybe defend first we play
this
this move
i want to i want to point again that
taking this pawn among other things
probably just rook a8 and black is
getting the activity and getting his
pawns back so you don't really want that
but king knight is six kingdom seven uh
maybe we should try rogue d7
knight c6 king of seven
so how dangerous it might be if you
again i'm just going to show how
dangerous if you go for this type oh
wait that actually just loses a piece so
as soon as i see the evil bar slide i
know there's some blunder and then i
spot it but okay even if you back up
i mean
already this is this is looking better
and better for black the h3 pawn is weak
by the way am i
am i able to take care now on rookie
three i can maybe move my king if it's
possible
maybe you have king d if
this is the two or five d5 d6 you can
actually attack the knight let's say
knight e4
rookie three i can play actually king d6
maybe
no this is scary knight is seven yeah
okay all right so
the point is again and we we said it
earlier
with before we had concrete reason to do
so and i and i said it because it was
like a car with biositus i was like look
when we were all the way back as far as
this position i was already saying it's
an equal end game but hicaro has played
a lot of these end games as black seen
it many times against very strong
grandmasters online chess or not i think
acaro is proving that we can we can stop
having to constantly justify that
high-level chess can also be played
online because it is and ricardo plays
more high-level chess online than
probably anybody on the planet and i've
just seen him win these end games as
black so often because it's a very tame
position for white black has a very
clear plan to expand as we've seen and
create weaknesses
and i don't know exactly where the
novelty idea occurred or where report
went wrong but i already feel really
uncomfortable about this position
uh
for uh for the person playing white and
hikaru has one psychological battle here
as well because first of all uh richard
played knight a5
uh with the idea of well
taking on b7 and at some point that you
cannot play b6 because knight c6 yes so
hikaru played a very good move c5
and he
simply proves him wrong because what is
your knight doing on a5 now
unless you want to play knight c6 after
b6 and then your knight has literally no
moves which is which is maybe what's
going to happen but as a car is pointing
out we're not afraid of this line at all
so
this is the opposite in terms of
spiciness that we have into palm to
sheep arusha but on that note let's back
up to our bird's eye view because i do
see chat
um
yelling at us to uh to head back over to
napalmashuparuja because apparently
ali reza's last move
was not the best move according to the
computer
already claiming a plus two maybe maybe
more advantage for napalm machine so
we're gonna we're gonna head over to
that game here and uh
and dive into it as soon as soon as we
can here because i want to see what
exactly is so concrete about white's
advantage
and he's very long time as well
yeah and very good point ali reza has
taken a ton of time
we see that they're only on move 23 so
again set the stage for the uphill
battle that ollie reza farooqia is
facing here
the position is already
very very maybe bad maybe maybe
dangerous we're gonna dive in the
analysis maybe there's a concrete line
for white but either way you're playing
a position with a king that's not safe
and only 30 minutes to make 17 moves
it's a very difficult situation to be in
um and it all started again as as we we
talked about the opening theory here
this this
novel maybe novel move not necessarily
novel idea from yonda palmishi to change
the move order a little bit and
farouza has been facing fire so what
exactly is the concrete problem
the last move was knight to d6
and and before that
before that the eval barb we didn't say
it was too bad so it means there's
something kind of creepy i mean the
first thing i look at is that the bishop
is blocked like can i just take the pawn
oh my gosh right as i say it you're on
the plumber she takes oh man he gives
the frowny face i've seen that frowny
face before
that's a yawn who thinks his his
opponent just blundered big time
exactly yes is absolutely sure that he's
sure
she just wondered
and it's a very important pound
i'm sorry
oh man i apologies for the excitement
hashtag no apology needed danny sorry
not sorry because i think we have some
crazy chess about to happen here he's
just winning he just won a pawn
so what's uh
furuja looking for uh rook b8 knight c4
you know trying to
put the queen
maybe i can't go here because of
discovery so i'll just come back okay i
guess i have to go to e1 if i go to d2
almer's point is that the b pawn is
pinned so there's likely some sort of
shot with knight to c4
but if you just go to e1
i'm not even sure you can't go to h4 by
the way okay no i guess the discovery
comes with c3 too much so yeah queen e1
is definitely the best
well
he needs to activate his pieces
desperately so that's why i was looking
for b8 and knight c4 but this doesn't
give you much here
yeah and one of the biggest problems for
black's position when you win that pawn
in these sicilians is very often well
let's remind everybody of kind of the
storyline of these games we've been
saying elmira what did we we talked a
lot about how in opposite side castles
games both sides are going to sacrifice
pawns to open up attacking lines right
and so black is like willing to blow up
in the center with d5 and the panda she
says i'll raise you one i'm sacrificing
to open up your king
and and that is the story both sides
want to attack but the moment you lose a
b4 pawn in these sicilians suddenly
white has a second storyline which is
all i have to do in this game is
simplify because if you take pieces off
the board if you just start imagining
pieces are getting traded here everyone
white has three
past pawns
c4 c5 d6 see this this game is over
positionally so
a risk that comes to every sicilian
player who launches a minority attack
like this is that if you if you get a
checkmate
assault then it's it was a good idea
but if your pawns become targets and
they fall
all of a sudden white has two things to
play for not just not just the the
attack over here that i started with f6
but just simplifying the game here so
i
i think that yonder palmishi is
feeling it in this game and
he's pacing now that's a confident pace
but let's have a look at another move so
after queen before i was um
searching
for right square for the night let's see
can i go knight f5 here or after d6 it's
losing immediately i don't know
oh you said d6 yes that's a nice move i
didn't see it but just show the idea of
takes elmira's idea is just to take here
and
probably just this and it's over yeah
and if you take with the bishop right
away similarly you're just you're losing
material in these positions if even if
if knight takes there's like bishop g5
and it's just it's falling apart
so so this is not working neither um
i i don't even think all the reza
probably missed this i think that i
think that you could probably argue with
with the clock disadvantage he was
facing
you know he was feeling that the
preparation pressure maybe he was like
well like if he takes the pawn at least
he's opening up lines against the king
and giving me some sort of practical
chances i i don't know i mean i could be
totally wrong
but i'm just trying to imagine like what
was the idea
of giving this before pawn we we saw
yon's reaction
he just doesn't think it's any good okay
let's try rugby a queen a one you said
then okay knight b5
at least something
and i see the moves i want to play i'm
just gonna play like c4 okay and you
want to play c4 and and
the night cards this the pawn guard this
is just like this is just so hard to
play black yes the knight on c1 is
is just by the way your d6 move might
even be possible here or even knight f5
because you're not actually threatening
anything
right
like
there's no knight c3 check
there's no bishop before
so c4 is good but even what if i play
like knight f5 here like
okay computer doesn't like it as much
but i'm just like that's just another
move like
what is black doing in this position
maybe i still have something like some
trick knight e4 to play for
after 95 so
but
objectively speaking this position is
completely lost after queen before
and so then we're coming back to the
story line which is
meaning when i when i say the story i
mean this is the game like he's got
16 moves to make
in an objectively lost position
in 25 minutes
and that's why we see the most nervous
ali reza faruja we've seen
so far here in madrid
well he certainly knows what is the
objective evaluation of the position is
and now he's trying to to find a way how
to um
create cows probably he needs to keep
the pieces on the board so he cannot go
for any sort of end game
he cannot exchange the
well the bishop for the knights so how
to keep
the pieces on the board
that's the only way to to continue
okay he's moved
i didn't see didn't see it at all oh
rook c8 okay
um
[Music]
that's interesting
he's preparing uh
knight c4
he's starting knight c4 because that
would attack the queen although i still
love your d6
in response to any move
yeah this is this is the second
objectively this might be the second
mistake in a row like knight knight d6
and then roxane it's it's harder to
really classify this the second one is a
big mistake because we're already
looking oops we're already looking at a
position where
hard to suggest better play for black
but
but yeah i mean
white is picking flavors here
i i can't play knight f5 anymore so
that's one good thing of the night still
being here
but what's the move for white that makes
rook city a blunder maybe that's what we
just don't see yet maybe there's
something but i don't really think of
this move in terms of a blunder oh
neither do i no i think black is already
in such a bad spot it's it's hard to
hard to blame them for further mistakes
okay let's uh just ask a trivial
question can i take the pawn on a3 of
course i will i'm not thinking about it
but you can use knight c4 so that's
as you can see this works here so you
you can no longer take the spawn yep
okay so rook c8
threatens knight c4 well you should take
on a3 okay
we've well what if i so again i made a
point which about winning this pawn that
is why i'm worried regardless of like
the concrete stuff here and and the time
pressure facing frugia it's that when
you win the b-pawn the game becomes
objectively so much easier for white
because before the way my story to win
elmira was an attack
right to justify my pawn sack so you see
what move i'm building to i'm like can i
play queen b6 am i missing something
okay i am clearly no no no but it's not
that you're missing that i will i will
not i will not take on b6 here so like
you'll avoid the queen trade
also i'm looking yes for some uh way to
um exploits i just want to get pieces
off the board because i've
i've won the game if the if if the
attack peter's out
i want to keep the uh queens on board
and to aim once again after 27 i can
play
knight b5 and
knight c3
you see this becomes possible yeah okay
so you're threatening that that makes
sense so i need to find a better move so
queen to b6
was my straightforward way to say i've
won a pawn let me just simplify but that
doesn't work so what else can i do here
um what if i do the same move i was
going to play on rook to b8 can i come
back
e1
get the queen out of the discovered
attack put pressure on e5
you can see from the eval bar that it's
just how hard this position is i'm
making moves that feel very logical but
clearly black has attacked because now
you probably just start
attacking and i would bet on c4 you're
probably sacrificing right of course
yeah you're just like taking
and
just
and now now black is is maybe
objectively winning so again i
definitely don't want to paint the
picture that this game is over at all
but
concrete play here and white's material
advantage is is just significant on the
queen side so but we've tried a few
moves
or they're both losing yeah so that's
not easy queen e1 queen c7
it's not losing i mean listen after c4
but queen a3 is losing queen 1 c4 is
losing exactly okay so that's queen b6
is uh not that clear to me
yeah so faruja has given yon something
to think about here
and he and that was a i was like all
right okay i feel you
i see you young fella
you're not going to make this easy
but this tea tastes great in case you're
wondering
that's what he just said with his eyes
um
you cannot bring the queen to the
king sides as well you cannot play
queen h4 for example if you want to
attack yourself because there is knight
a4 coming
yeah
maybe we can show it just in case so if
i play queen h4
you know i assumed it was 95 right even
95. yeah so
and then then everything is coming
that is hikaru nakamura standing with
hands on hip observing
i know that stance anywhere
hi karo
which means hikaru is probably feeling
pretty confident over in his battle
versus report um the only person we
should allow to stand in front of our
cameras if shakira
shakira yes to have the dance yeah if
she's if she or any flamenco dancer in
general um okay a move has been played
but what oh bishop to b6
oh actually
i wanted the queen to be six
this move the computer loves what's the
what's the idea so the queen will find a
square similar to queen b6 what's the
concrete
you no longer have quincy seven
ah so i can play this is so deep this is
so deep this move is really very strong
it's so funny you put a piece on a
flimsy square and now this idea yep that
was it
because
because now there's no way for the queen
to enter the c file and attack c2
so bishop to b6
forces the black queen to an awkward
square but more importantly takes away
the only ability to attack on the c file
so okay i played queen e1 because that
was the move we tried that failed the
queen c7 maybe there's even other good
moves here for white but but this
this seems decent to attack the pawn
and again like
if you start making moves like this and
you're not all in in an attack okay
this move
but i want to try queen b7
okay i i want to just take here and then
go full fisher on f6 here oh yes you
have queen e5 and rook f6 of course so
this is possible i think it is
no this is completely winning so queen
b7 is simply not possible because
otherwise we would transpose
and i will be attacking your bishop and
plays queen c7
yeah but queen e5 is running immediately
well we've got uh we've got some feature
chat coming in for the first time today
thanks for being with us all of you no
matter where you are
tal dar anton la
that is way too many consonants in a row
for this dude but uh or vowels i'm
confused nepo found the best move
poggers
indeed he did find the best move bishop
to b6
we did not find the best we we tried
queen a3 we tried queen e1 weren't
working but
this was great yawn depth 100 napalm
mishi um
i agree with this one this is a great
one yeah hesi timbo
the brontologist
nepo deep deep
deep in the chest sauce
finding nepo no mo we're no longer
finding nepa we found him he's right
there
playing the white side
of maybe a brutal english attack
d7 is almost forced i think i think 27
is forced and
yawn is about to uh
take a walk
because he's got to take furrow to
school i tried to get to a chess school
i couldn't get in
yawn taken for russia to school right
now
lakers two three two four that might be
the next time they win a championship
hey yo come on shout out shout out to
all those laker fans out there
being tortured by that dysfunctional
situation uh 23-24 the next time the
lakers will win a championship uh that
is that is the year
of
of the future so thank you
all right that was fun
thank you again chat continue to play
along with us you're the reason we're
here
appreciate all the subscribers coming in
today we saw you we love you thank you
so much um
elmira
well mayor now thinks that maybe knight
d7 was um was a good move because
now we've seen what happened so maybe to
keep the pressure
ruxin maybe 97 first to prevent bishop
b6
i like that actually did you just refer
to yourself in the third person you said
i'll mirror now
[Laughter]
[Music]
danny now thinks he's going to show
elmira's idea on the board which she was
saying knight to d7 was maybe a better
move than rook to ch
yeah i mean i think black is still in a
really really
really tough spot but
so while you're talking nonsense elmira
is
i'm talking nonsense almira's over here
referring to herself in the third person
um
well this is the opposite story of of
yesterday's game it was for ruja who
brought the prep to hikaru right for
ruja who at one point was up what like
an hour and a half on the clock right
and if not for you know a brilliant
swindle from nakamura
and and some very very deep
understanding um that game probably ends
in a victory for for the youngest player
here in madrid
but
but this is the opposite this has been
yon napomnishi's game from start to
finish elmira
and i think he's going to get his second
victory and i'm going to go on a limb
and say he will be the clear leader
of the 2022 feta candidates after this
round
not maybe not a limb
i know you're about to say easy easy
easy there dan don't give yourself too
much credit because there's no way bobby
wins against dingley run but i am i'm i
think this is over i think he's going to
win this game and i think yonder palmer
she will be your clear leader after four
rounds this might as well be
what we call a chess miniature you know
i don't i don't see how he can last for
well another five moves what do we
define a miniature at at the top levels
these days because he beat dingley wren
in 36 moves i think i think in game one
36 or 37 moves
i mean
traditionally under 20 moves is
considered a miniature at the top level
these days i agree any game that ends
under move 40 when a decisive result is
that was a you know what i mean brought
the pain well but sometimes you're
you're well you're looking at 30 moves
of home analysis so it's it's not that
easy to trap your opponent first of all
so yeah when this happens i think that's
uh
if he survives till the move 30 it will
be a miracle
sorry i mean uh
stickers on the back of the ipad for you
to see i just thought it was funny
so what are you taking before the shows
commentators need you know
mental strengths and physical endurance
to go through the show as you say
in your video yep
okay well
this is uh
as we said the op the opposite storyline
potentially of of what
we had on sunday with ali reza bring the
prep to the table and on that note while
he might be
about to experience a learning moment he
is still very young
um
he brought he brought it big time
in uh
in the last game we had before the break
we had a highlight video to show you
reminding you of all that was that epic
epic first ever classical chess battle
between nakamura by the way y'all just
all over it finds queenie one like right
away uh
that epic battle between farrugia and
nakamura let's check in with what that
highlight video was we're gonna keep
this game up don't worry everybody won't
miss any action and we will be back
after you after you remind yourself of
just how awesome that game was
despite their many online battles ali
reza faruja and hikaru nakamura had
never contested a classical game that
changed in round three of the fide
candidates as alireza opened with the
white pieces and won d4 hikaru responded
with the nimzo indian
ali reza revealed deep and dangerous
preparation as he used no time on the
clock to reach move 16 and sacrifice a
piece on g5 a sacrifice that received
the brilliant annotation from game
review
though the engine claimed an eval of
0.00 the position was incredibly sharp
and treacherous for hikaru he sank deep
into thought
engine perfect defense led hikaru into a
difficult decision pursue a sharp line
where he would win an exchange or enter
a worse end game hikaru ultimately
selected the end game this position is
absolutely amazing as wild as it seems
this is not outside of the realm of
possibility right because
how deep does ferocious prep go
everybody
in the end game alireza quickly created
and advanced connected past pawns on the
king side with pressure on the clock and
board mounting the commentators began to
believe that hikaru might be losing are
we moments away from perugia
getting his first victory at the
candidates another brilliant move sent
ali reza's pawn all the way to the sixth
rank consuming the last of his time
hikaru got the rooks off the board and
targeted a scary position he had
calculated it to be a fortress alireza
got his connected past pawns all the way
to the sixth and seventh rank a single
move away from promotion then hikaru
played pawn to c3
and left the board c3 look at that
counter play i actually wait and ricardo
stood up from the board like he
okay wait hold the phone everybody we
were anointing for ruja but something
has gone wrong here
alireza began thinking
shockingly there was no way through and
after using up an hour and a half
alireza rapidly blitzed out the finish
conceding the draw hikaru had used only
three minutes on the clock after his
critical pawn to c3 i'm flipping bone
blown away by hikaru nakamura in this
game
the moment he played c3 elmira he spent
a total of maybe three minutes at the
board in the last two hours like he knew
it was a draw before stockfish did
probably one of the most
intense jaws that i've ever seen
hey there everybody we're back we're
back at the instructive monitor and chat
before you before you yell at us about
the glare here you're going to want to
you're going to want this breakdown here
because our own almiros kripchenko did
some amazing research about the
theoretical preparation that ali rosa
perugia brought to the board against
on sunday and uh we wanted to we wanted
to show you just how deep and smart ali
reza's shuffling was in the opening so
as we said this position has been played
many times at the high level and hikaru
nakamura has played black in this
position maybe more than any of the
world's elite in this position magnus
carlsen tried e3 against hikaru nakamura
unsuccessful in getting a win that game
was a draw in fact richard report the
last time he played hikaru in this
position played e3 the person that
hikaro was playing today also failed to
get a win against icaru holds this
position for breakfast or dinner i
actually don't know which he prefers
better so hikaru holds this position as
black all the time and in fact even
laquan liam tried to move e4 in an
online battle against nakamura and
that's the most important one i want to
leave with before we show why ali reza
played queen c2 because it was this move
that hicarro played the same idea of
bishop f1
rook f1
g5
but in this line because
lewanglion played e4 before the queen
being in the dangerous position that she
was ready to help with the attack hikara
was able to meet the sacrifice with the
immediate strike of e5 if you remember
this is not how he was able to deal with
farouz's prep but this move immediately
stops white from the idea that we know
is coming in these positions which is e5
and in this game as well hikar was able
to hold so what's the difference between
the theory that ferugia uncorked
compared to what everyone else has tried
to do here well the move queen to c2
one extra tempo is a patient move by the
queen preparing e4 but it also brings
the queen to a position where she was
much more dangerous if you remember in a
lot of the lines we saw so in that game
after c5 a move that proves not to be as
useful as what black needs ferugia goes
for e4 and after the trade on f1 and the
sacrifice occurs in this position it is
much harder
for black to deal with the attack
because of the move queen to c1 it was
this shuffling if you remember that
first put hiccaro into the very very
deep think because yes e5 was possible
here and no i'm not going to be at the
telestrator for half an hour to show you
how e5 loses but the main point is that
because the queen is on this diagonal
and because f4 is coming this position
is way more dangerous for black than
when hikaru played e5 against the quang
li m so it was this idea and this
shuffling that forced tekaru to go for
the lines in rook takes d4 and
ultimately gave farrugia the advantage
that he had in this variation with queen
of four now of course as we know he was
unable to go on to win this end game but
that doesn't change the evaluation that
i think says we may not see hikaru go
for this exact line again in this
tournament i think that he was in
trouble in that game before finding the
c3 and i think farrugia would would love
a second chance to convert on this end
game as well so anyway interesting
theoretical battle there that just shows
us how great farouz's queen to c2 move
was and how much it was this close to
beating nakamura unfortunately for ali
reza he's in the opposite chair today
facing brilliant prep from yonda
pomneshi so how's that for the glare
take that chat
hell mirror
i was trying to calculate how many moves
white made with the queen you know in
order to have an advantage in this game
yeah how many queen moves does it take
to screw in a light bulb as they say
right
quincy two yes quincy three could say
four kidney four quincy two back so full
circle yeah no full circle the queen
moved one two three four five and if you
include queen c one six times right in
the first almost 15 16 moves there in
order to have the attack that perugia
did so
anyway yeah um
we've uh we've we've
we've had a good time hope you enjoyed
that chat i i don't know how you feel
about chat you you did like it yes my
yes
is that my yes to the glare or my yes to
the analysis
oh my eyes apparently i can't uh read
good today i didn't go for the school
that that for kids that read good well
we know that i'm completely blind but if
we're losing you you know if we're
losing me we're in trouble no but okay
well i apologize for the glare chat but
it was a lot of fun and hopefully you
enjoyed that the breakdown oh mirror you
you get you get tons of credit for that
sort of breakdown in showing what ali
reza rezafarug's preparation was where
it at least started with that queen c2
shuffle and yeah not enough glare for
for roja mz i'll work on it if you want
i can point the light even more directly
at it um you're welcome um
so i thought that was that was a really
instructive point because i think it
actually plays to some storyline which
is that
hikaru drew that game
but i do believe he got away with one
and that's what great players do right
and faruga didn't quite convert but i
thought the research we did was super
important because either hikaru's team
has to work on something in that line or
don't be surprised i'll call it now if
the next time hicaro's black and someone
is offering that line in the nimzo we
see hikaru very first because i think
that line is actually very dangerous for
black with this idea that puja came up
with this land is very dangerous first
of all it's now very easy to target
hikaru in his preparation and also
there's so much information that we have
to deal with with nowadays that you have
to analyze blitz games bullet games you
know and sometimes even a bullet game
can reveal you know your home
preparation yep
even a bull game yes yes i'm pretty sure
that uh well it's not only
correspondence just the three it's funny
because again we talk how online chess
doesn't need to justify itself anymore
there's lots of serious online chess but
it's right that even bullet just because
these guys play so many games that
they're not always thinking
i'm gonna hide my prep right they're
just thinking just play chess and win
right and so if you look closely enough
it's even some of the bullet games right
bullet and blitz they might be playing
things that give you a little bit of a
hint
of what they would do in an
over-the-board battle so i i really love
that point um
but speaking of icaru the guy who plays
a lot of bullet and often plays his
openings that he would play in over the
board battles in that bullet chest
we see him on the clock here
not quite sure how to deal with this
knight d5 retreating move by report at
least that's what
initially confused face hickor maybe
tell me but no either that or he's just
thinking about how can i keep an edge
because maybe if he plays the right move
here there's still a chance for him to
be pressing yes but f4 is yeah yeah f4
is on the agenda
um
well it seems that he missed something
in his calculations because uh
white
has improved
its position a lot since the last time
we saw it
let's we're going to dive into that yeah
we'll dive into
to report nakamura because i think that
you're right that probably something was
missed
so let's let's do that let's back up to
where where did we leave it ricardo
played b6
right yes
you said that he
wait wait no wait in a second here
before we dive in it
for the team to catch up with us there
we go so we hikara played b6 this is
where we left the game
and after knight to c6 check king e6
knight takes
played brooke a this is this is what we
thought was was good
but after an ip5 takes in knight c7
this was the exact line we looked at
no we we didn't because that was the
position with without h3 being included
and it looked very dangerous so now
there is it's
this position is completely different so
yeah we we were first pointing out amir
and elmira is totally correct that
we we established that like in some
other lines we established i think it
was even king of one
that taking a seven was not a big deal
because black has ideas of rook a8
but
but we didn't really point out that h3
takes away a pawn that by the way
previously would have captured on
passant on f4 so now as we catch up to
the game
at the end of this line report is
showing an interesting idea which is hey
your king looks really good on e5 that's
a centralized king but
don't lose a piece while you're at it
if you take e4 i assume it's knight
takes f6 check and we're just getting
closer to a draw so
so he caro has to be really careful here
if he wants to keep pushing and also be
careful not to lose i mean the king is
in a tactically very sort of precarious
spot here
of course well now he has to well once
again switch gears and to find
a precise way
to equalize here because
well the pound on b6 is hanging as well
so let's say if i
put to take it knight b6 you cannot take
on b2 knight c4 check as well so there's
no comfortable way to get your pawn back
here for black
yeah i'll just
show some line i mean how do we
first of all rook b2 here doesn't work
yes so yeah it takes here there's knight
to c4 check so
and then you lose the game so yeah
ricardo has a lot to figure out and
one of the things that uh
that that he's probably debating right
now is whether he should just go for
some sort of simplification line and
just like peer this one out but you said
initially is that plan coming in would
be to get a draw as black
right um but uh
maybe he thought he could push and maybe
now he's like i want to be a little
careful here um they're all moved 32 but
with plenty of time left i don't imagine
they'll get in time pressure so we
should probably head back to nepal nishi
furuja because as far as a game that
doesn't have a lot of time left
to reach time control
that is
ali reza's position as black and he is
he is thinking right now about how to
deal with queen to e1 and i'm not sure i
mean you called it on there you said
this game might be over in five moves i
think you might be right
well we cannot find a move here you know
he has only five minutes left and we
have an eval bar and an occasional
engine if we want to turn it on
so um
yep
remember it's not just that he has five
minutes everybody it's that he has 14
moves to make in five minutes that's a
very difficult thing to accomplish in a
position where you're objectively
losing so it's a hard thing to
accomplish if you have an advantage 14
moves in five minutes is a hard thing to
do
even if you're better but um
it might be an impossible task
for today's game
you cannot play e4 bishop d4 you're just
winning a minute lights increase winning
on the spot yep e4 bishop d4
uh knight to b5 was a move that we kept
calling for but i think we said just
queen takes e5 although that allows
knight c3 actually in this line just c4
c4 right
so knight b5 c4
e4 bishop d4 and queen b7 really takes
e5 queen b7 queen f5 reanalyzed so
uh we've ran out of options i think
running out of options he's running out
of time
so what is that what does that do right
obviously ali reza ruja came in a lot of
high hopes by a lot of people although
also as he said i don't have a lot of
expectations on myself you know but
if you experience your first loss at a
tournament like this
your mindset has to go to don't tilt
maybe get a draw in your next game
right um and and be happy that you have
more whites than blacks ahead in your
future i'm thinking the free day also
has something to do with it because you
know it's like you're playing a
tournament here you have a pace and you
know every day probably you know changed
something for uh furuja australia is uh
he's like maybe he wanted to play once
again yeah well yeah you have to prepare
you know
maybe you cannot sleep yep and this is
definitely uh
well once again a factor that we should
consider all those practical factors
matter because
okay let's hear everybody that three
minutes i mean we keep talking about the
time control on this clock there is no
increment coming
so that's literally three minutes for
now
uh
still
13 i guess 13 moves with this last move
we ate
i want to come back to what you're
talking about elmira because how much of
that
is like chess players are creatures of
habits in some way you know um when
you're in a rhythm
right you're in the flow
then you have a rest day which should be
good it's not like he went into the
wrestling on a loss you know he's doing
okay he's doing great even right three
three good draws good good showing for a
19 year old kid in their first
candidates
but if you change anything and then
you're superstitious right you have
something different for breakfast
because it was a three because it was a
free day you went to a different
restaurant right something that i know i
know it sounds silly but
those types of thoughts like affect
chess players right because if things
are going well and you do anything
different you're thinking oh did i just
like upset the chess gods or something
like that well i definitely feel that
when you're 19
you want to play every game i remember
that i wanted to play if the olympian
would be i don't know
at the time there were 13 games at the
olympiad you know i wanted to play them
all in one day in one day
and now i'm thinking oh my god you know
when is the free day so i do understand
this
but now that i think of rook v8
he found a very interesting way to
continue and not to lose on the spot
okay what's the idea the idea first of
all is is that you uh you're attacking
the bible you're attacking the bishop
and you didn't open the big diagonal you
didn't play e4 uh queen e5 is it
possible here now just let me see maybe
it was but john
john's still just playing lightning fast
here plays bishop a5 to come to c3
because i wanted to play knight c4 and
queen e5 that was some kamikaze idea
that i had no no just when the bishop
was on b6
just uh just to see if queen e5 here oh
after would be it yes
but my hero probably isn't as good
because
knight c4 maybe
no apparently that's winning for white
oh right you can just take yeah and
rugby six and knight b3 okay then it
doesn't work but maybe rook b6 then
there should be something that um
so
like after queen e5 because why
why not to play it then
why play it i do no i mean like
let's get back to the position one one
last time which position rugby eight
okay why don't we play queen e5 here
it's probably winning but why why do
anything different like i mean i can
take it
yeah
rook takes f6 maybe it's definitely for
here okay so it's something like this
okay
okay but the biggest issue in this
position is is
maybe not even what's facing him on the
board elmira it's it's on the clock
13 moves to make
he has
one minute and 50 seconds
and he's already shaking his head
because he's nervous you just saw him
glance over i mean the you have two
enemies in this position one of them is
the board the other one is the clock and
i don't know that uh that he's gonna get
out of this because how do you how do
you make a move here
there we don't we don't have a good move
to suggest
for black
well i don't know i my hands are shaking
when i'm getting down to five minutes
with increments yeah okay he does find a
move which is okay but look at the body
language there already like super
dejected frustrated plays knight to c4
i think the thing we have to highlight
here is obviously ali rez is in the
tough spot but we got to give yon a ton
of credit look at this is this right
here everyone take a snapshot this is
the yonda pomnashie that got himself
into a world chess championship match
against magnus carlson that whole time
he's pacing elmira he's not messing
around he's thinking about the game so
the moment he sits down he can make a
move and put pressure back on only
resident furuga on the clock
this is what he does maybe better than
anybody in the world when he's feeling
it is use the clock as a weapon
i expect him to play bishop c3
pretty quickly here unless he's already
calculated some other win and uh
and farouz is running out of running out
of tricks here
maybe this is the equivalent of like
well okay as long as you don't make a
blunder it's like it's like keeping
possession in like in like a sporting
game as long as you keep possession of
the ball the clock will beat your
opponent you don't have to score anymore
right there's no more scoring to be done
here for young play bishop c3
whatever right because at this point
alireza's not doesn't have enough time
to make the 13 moves remaining
well you are completely right
and bishop c3 is a very
good move
bringing that bringing the bishop back
to well to the big diagonal and then
simply take only five
yeah there's there's nothing
the problem is any move that yon makes
is basically the equivalent of keeping
the ball and
varusha has nothing to do
this is uh
honestly this is i think this is
actually less less
time management mistake by ferruja and
more just that he ran up against
preparation i mean because john has used
no time and farouza was clearly out of
depth the moment that jan played g takes
f6 if we're looking at this game in
hindsight what else was he supposed to
do he was just getting out prepared out
pushed right maybe i'm wrong do you
think he could have managed the clock
better you think is this is this also a
lesson in time management
well that was
also such a complicated position but on
the other hand like
this is such a natural move you cannot
be surprised by gta x6
like you know when it was played that's
that cannot be a surprise when you're
playing this line with black
yeah that's fair
but
but something was off because look at
his clock then right
immediately responds with bishop d8
um
by the way ali reza not even taking the
time to write his move down
now he now he is he wanted to make sure
that if jan responded he was ready to
play quickly didn't want to get down on
the clock
um
by the way we weren't even talking about
d6 that was also a
pretty good move for white
well
maybe he can simply take on d8
now he can take on d8 i can still play
bishop c3 which is the move that i i
just feel like the bishop is so happy on
that diagonal it's just like great but
but bishop d8 forces queen did
you know because the knight on f6 is
hanging so
the ship takes da queen takes d8 and you
can do
anything right again knight to five
nine at five that looks great
we can show it on the board i think it's
a very simple variation so uh
i think people can just
quickly know that if the queen comes to
g3
we have big problems
there's
yawn has an hour one of the things
that's so out of balance about this game
is that yawn
we're sitting here like it's imminent
right and it could be imminent for
ferugia we could also be staring at this
game for another 45 minutes if yon
decides hey i have an hour on the clock
i'm just going to chill
daniel gould nepo is the goat uh
he's
this is this is the nepo that that could
be winning the candidates um
i don't know that the jr key knows that
nepambashi has his own catalog of facial
expressions hicaro is not the only
emotive player yawn is also
yon is also a bit of a meme in terms of
his reactions
to chess moves so
it will be the catch me if you can
situation if he wins this game
i like that
that's actually
a really important point and what i'm
saying and again
because on that note from tizzy q
is if yon wins this game
he's already in a spot where a draw is
like never a bad result right and so
even just a half a point lead over over
someone like favi assuming fabi draws
might be enough to just continue to play
super solid super safe which by the way
makes people play more risky chess
against you and then maybe you get more
victories right and so this is this is a
huge early game
for yonda palmishi's chance to win the
candidates
is he talking to himself right now like
yeah just
taking his time taking his time
there's multiple good moves here though
i mean again if anyone's wanting bishop
bishop takes d8 is elmira said and then
knight of five i keep calling for bishop
c3 because it just feels so so warm and
cozy
you could even play bishop c7 by the way
because if takes takes twice am i not
winning a piece at the end of that line
so if you can't take it you move the
rook and
and then i play knight f5 maybe
yes but this is a very easy position to
play you know with white suits
we should simply wait for a move i think
well like we said i know we're we're
imminent um and there
we will certainly not go anywhere else
the moment aldi reza ferrugia is on the
clock but with yonder palmishi on the
clock we'll back up to our bird's eye
view and just look at where the other
games stand hikaru did play the move
knight to e6 to stop the f4 fork from
report
shout out to fabi for
holding what looks like
a game that uh he knew better than we
did he's down a pond in that position
but it looks like it's getting closer
and closer
to a clear result of a draw although
i don't know how he corrals built those
pawns we might have to go look at that
in a little bit i don't know if you see
it but um and then and then the last one
we haven't looked at in a while
is probably one that we may not look
very much at
again because
looks although those double pawns for
for rajab are not too great out mirror
those double def pawns
well but in this position you are
fighting for the one for the only open
file so as long as long as you can keep
control we have liftoff bishop c3 has
been played so faruja back on the clock
immediately responds with queen to e6
yawn played the solid move bishop c3 my
favorite
but faroosh is ready so give him credit
for that right he knows he has no time
so he's got 11 moves now in a minute
i wonder i wonder how these guys feel
sometimes about a guy that's been under
time pressure a lot in his life meaning
online time like
furushi can make a hundred moves in a
minute if you're playing online you know
what i mean but time pressure over the
board very very different and without
increment i wonder how much more nervous
he is in this situation but i feel that
while it's still very important when
you're playing online you don't have the
same kind of responsibility on your
shoulders yeah feel like make a mistake
online okay that's online you know that
didn't really happen and that's actually
how our brain perceives
certain situations while you're making
this mistake during the candida days oh
yeah very different it's very different
so
uh yeah he he knows that this is
this is going to be a tough one to crawl
out of but right now he can't think
about what he has to do after the game
he's got to figure out is there any way
for me to pull off a miracle here that's
why he's working hard on his opponent's
time
uh i think that was fabiano taking a bit
of a walk saying i think i'm confidently
holding a draw over there against
dingley run
yawn head in hand
nope maybe he was about to move nope
i'm thinking maybe if feruge is trying
to
win
the pawn back the d6 spawn for the
moment the knight on c4 is protecting
the pawn and f5
but if i can
this is an interesting point if i can
stabilize the position are you aware of
this rule that he doesn't have to keep
notation because it's a non-increment
time control
under five minutes
oh this no yeah apparently the rule is
that under five minutes he doesn't have
to write them down the arbiter will keep
track because there's no increment
because i cuz what's funny is
i know that's the opposite rule in in
most tournaments where you have
increment you're not allowed to go more
than two moves no matter how bad your
time pressure is writing it down in fact
if your opponent calls it on you more
than once you can you can be penalized
right
but apparently the rule is here because
there's no increment if they're under
five minutes he's not actually required
to write the move down but it's in your
role that certainly didn't apply to
classical chess before like before
before but i think the increment is the
distinction no but like before when
you're playing all these candidates
tournaments and uh you you had to write
your moves down okay well we'll get a
fact check on that then we'll look at
that i'm actually curious about that
because i i was drawing i was drawing
the attention to the fact that farouza
has not been writing his moves down
right away have you seen a squishy by
viktor korchnoy like when he's in time
travel yeah just scribbles just like
it's not even
i don't
know like literally it's worse than a
doctor yes yeah it's a famous thing in
fact there are a lot of people with
reputations who fulfill the obligation
of writing it down but they've got
perfect notation for the first 30 moves
and then literally like
it's not legible right so they're
basically breaking the rules
by by fulfilling the obligation to write
something down so these are fun things
that happen in over-the-board chess that
you would never never think are an issue
if you've if you're of the pogchamps
crew
never never watched an event like this
so
jana is still thinking you know
i'm looking at this position and i i
know
what like he's thinking about and it's
it's not the movies he knows that don't
spoil it don't spoil it i'm pretty sure
there's something which is a
sort of mantra
it's it's funny because what i'm saying
is is the psychology of what's going on
in yon's head right and sometimes that
can like that can affect you when
there's so many winning moves and
because now you become you become
someone who's like just don't screw this
up which is not a healthy place to be
and more than likely he will not screw
it up because he's very good at chess
and he's in a completely winning
position
but
but when you're playing uh like against
an opponent who has only one minute in
on the clock in this situation and you
have more than one hour the thing is
that you were
tempted to play immediately so
this could be you know a crucial mistake
you need to take your time so it's not
like fergie is uh responding instantly
yeah and jan i know that he's tempted
yeah i've
you know lost many lost many advantages
by playing too fast when i was both
winning on the board and up on the clock
but i played too fast here we've got
crisis 87 saying why is it so important
to write down the moves
is it's a tradition but it's not needed
anymore in modern top level tournaments
so we actually talked about this in an
earlier show it's it's not really true
it it is still needed for a number of a
number of reasons um
but
we'll see if we have time you know we
can all let almira respond first and if
if something happens on the board we may
not be able to provide full explanation
but you gave a couple of really good
reasons why writing down the moves is
still relevant well of course first of
all you need this for claiming the
three-folder petition
then
well i was thinking about
a very simple thing as a legal proof
because the score sheet needs to be
signed by uh opponents from that point
of view crisis 87 there's you're right
that there's enough people watching this
that no one can lie about the result but
there are a lot of top level tournaments
where there are i mean like the grand
swiss for example the event that that we
you know helped organize with fide and
in terms of what qualified all the
reservoirs to get here
not every board has a camera and an
arbiter on it and without some sort of
written record which is that your
opponent signed the scoresheet that says
that you won
there could be collusion right so having
some sort of intellectual property that
proves that it went down is something
that's interesting that
although even in that case i guess if
all the games are dgt i mean
if they're online it's true i mean
it's it's not an un it's not an unlike
talked about topic i think there is a
topic that you know you could make an
argument that even threefold repetition
like we could evolve the rules and say
why should a player have to claim
three-fold repetition right if it
happens and the dgt board tracks it
should they just be notified that they
have the option right no because that
means that there's third party which is
interfering and true in the game so and
the third point is that which i wanted
to talk about just like you brushed up
on it's like that
it's
it's a different debate but if one day
we will talk about the intellectual
property you certainly need these games
to be written so yes
like composers do you know so yeah
that's true i mean
it could be you know you could have a
you could have a score sheet that you
know is worth a lot of something you
know i guess if you have the score sheet
that magnus carlsen used to win his
first world championship i would bet
that magnus has saved that scoresheet if
i had to guess um anyway
all right well yan is in a totally
winning position here in the in this
spot you could probably back up the
bishop to a1 you could probably even
take here and go to the end game if you
wanted
um
bishop takes e5
i don't know could it be considered as a
writer's manuscript like
the chess game it's like the writer's
manuscript you know i don't know if
this is a
right um example
yeah
but you know it's
again all that said to be fair like
those are those are reasons you know to
kind of justify the process when what do
we watch a lot of times they play rapid
tournaments and they don't have to keep
score in rapid chess right and or or
even the world blitz championship right
like technology has evolved to the point
where you know some of the practical
reasons we used to have to keep score
have gone away but intellectual property
is another thing the value of the score
sheet you know
anyway it's a fun fun little debate um
so what happened while i just i didn't
have
time to
look at the board so 93 95.
i guess i feel like we've stopped
analyzing deeply because we're kind of
just waiting for it to be over and it
could end any second but
it's not over yet
um
maybe yeah i mean you can't you can't
play knight at bishop a1 you can't
really put either knight on e3 because
white will play knight e5
yeah so bishop b1
i was looking at bishop e5 but
maybe you don't want to give this bishop
but you can exchange
everything
yeah you have to be a little careful
though yes bishop of six is gone yeah
mission six is coming there's some you
know there's some fun ways for white to
go wrong right if you if you do this i
think trading queens is bad because then
black has knight c3
so like okay like good example to go
wrong and if you
if you do this and take with the knight
maybe jan is worried about bishop f6
and of course if the knight moves okay
we know you can't do this but again just
showing that like so farouja is laying
every possible trap he can
to try to save this game
there's also
okay bishop bishop a1 was the move i was
suggesting okay and computer likes that
whoa wait
yawn plays knight f4 oh my gosh
that might be the knockout blow
that might be the move that that really
puts the game away
what a move that was by the way
that eliminates all the threats of
knight c3 takes the knight off the board
and keeps the bishop
alireza finds f6
to keep the balance a good defensive
move
but we didn't see 94 coming at all that
we were looking at bishop a1 or bishop
e5 this is a very strong move well he's
exchanging one of the most attacking
black pieces of course but
on the other hand
furujay is still there you know he is a
he didn't lose like in in five moves
like i predicted
knight to four knight to four and f6 he
closed the um
big diagonal and he protected the pawn
but why can't they take on c4 now quincy
four okay
you see i would have lost my queen e2
now that he's gotten out of the uh the
scramble of force tactics those are easy
moves to find but you know it's not that
easy subtle moves when you have 50
seconds for seven moves and we see
we see the look at that yawn gets up and
walks there's nothing more scary when
you have no time on the clock than your
opponent getting up and walking around
in fact it's kind of irritating so ali
reza makes a move and then looks over at
yawn
and he's like hey i'm working over here
and i've only got 30 seconds
shaking his head
i mean i will go back to that storyline
and say that the fact that the kid has
been able to hold on to this so well is
fantastic right
but it makes you look at the clock
differently and feel like wow like
should have been playing faster earlier
he was mismanaging his clock and from
the perspective that like the position
is not over yes white's winning but it's
not over yet
and this time trouble is probably going
to spell one more blunder before you
reach move 40. and how many moves do we
have left he has seven moves to make in
35 seconds
oh
that's okay but
i can take on b2
yeah you can just take and win a pawn
you can also just move your rook to
safety and i'm not really sure what the
knight is doing on b2
but where are you going the g6 spawn is
uh under attack as well so
oh that's true okay
so you can move the rook to d2 maybe
that was my point right oh maybe
no maybe you can go rook f1 and queen d6
you have bishop b5
you see this rook df1
here you are rook g1 now rook d f1
and if queen d6 then you have bishop b5
right that's why it's also winning
when we think about the the preparation
you made a comment on mirror that like
he shouldn't be surprised by this idea
because it's you know a common one
so then so then what's the um
what's the reason this when it went awry
is it is it just inexperience of
of of
you know the pressure that jan brought
is it did he did he confuse his lines
right so what what do you think was the
biggest reason he's spending i'm looking
back at this elmira he's spending
31 minutes on bishop takes f1
29 minutes on a3
10 minutes on king h8 and then if we
jump ahead on rook b8 another 17 minutes
right so i'm just like i'm trying to
unpack like where he just felt like it
just got away from him
well the first critical decision was of
course bishop f1 yeah and uh
from starting from this position it it's
all went wrong for
holly rosa
yeah this was this was the decision that
the computer didn't like the first time
that the edge started to slide in
white's favor
but
you could argue that it was even less
the move and more the fact that he took
uh 32 minutes to do it so i said 31 it
was actually closer to 32.
anyway obviously this is not over yet
john
looking to put this away but
you're going to you're going to be back
to the drawing board a little bit by the
way likes your move yawn likes your move
elmira rook df1 alireza sees the tactic
quickly plays brook to e8
i kind of like that young didn't take on
b2
kind of keeping the pressure there maybe
he'll slide the brook to h4 and now play
queen h5 and go back for go back to
checkmate he does it okay
30 seconds
30 seconds for five moves
shaking his head
farouza knows this one got away from him
not just on the board but on the clock
pushes f5
okay but
is is rook takes h7 already a
possibility probably
and is it winning rock h7 rook takes
seven takes and then queen h5 and my
point is that you can't play queen h6
because the rook hangs
everyone crowding around here this is
definitely going to be
the first game that finishes here in
round four
you mean king jay it's simply
[Music]
rook
f5 why is it winning there let's check
rook age seven
king age seven rook age seven king age
seven queen h5 i want to stay right here
because i okay i don't want to change
the live position or the or the view we
have on the clock because that is some
some nice work there we see the clock in
real time
for five more moves he has 17 seconds
no i think that after king james you
have knight to 5 and rook g1
maybe something like this i was just
saying rook h7 because it's not my rook
so i can just throw it out
but there's probably other moves too
like
uh you could probably even just put the
rook on a safe square like rook h5 right
and then go back to taking things maybe
but um
but okay yeah rook h7 might be
that would that would be you'd be how
nervous are you playing a move like rook
h7 when you don't need that move right
it might be unnecessary to stack your
rook when anything as i kept saying
possession is all white needs to win
this game to a degree right like just
keep the advantage keep the pressure and
and and ferocious time is is going to be
his greatest enemy that's where young is
going to uh to think for one hour yeah
john's gonna in fact he might look at
him taking some tea
all right
we've got the oh he takes some it takes
a look at farouza and kind of like uh i
got a lot of options here
so i guess we can do yeah now we can
look at it rook h7 king h7 queen h5 okay
we were right okay
so king chief okay and i assume we're
just taking with the knight yes that's
what i wanted to try and then rook g1 is
coming
but i want to see if like
just one move i was saying just rook h5
is also fine
rick h5 is yeah
like that's my boy like any move here
you just sit
now you cannot play a four because of
rookie five well i can i think i can
just take it right
or
so i was i was kind of kidding when i
said rook h7 but it looks like rook h7
is winning but even like the simple rook
h5 is winning
your your point is is exact rookie five
so
this is uh
definitely the most dramatic game of the
round is this the most dramatic game of
the tournament we've had so far
possibly it might be after that move
rook h7 king h7 yawn's gonna try to put
this one away in style everybody
he's not he's not settling on the
obvious or the safe rook h5 he's going
all in on the most forcing variation
and i think after knight f5 we might
even see a resignation
rather than losing on the clock look at
yon this is this is maybe the most
dominant
game we've seen to date in the 2022 feed
a candidates
the preparation from yawn was on point
and he's putting it away
with a massive advantage both on the
board and on the clock
pausing looking at ferruccia plays rook
g1
and the whole point is that king f8
queen h6 check so for rougeab resigns
we have a
massive victory for yon upon machine
what did you say almira catch me if you
can
that that's leonard dicaprio right there
playing the white pieces
and everyone else is tom hanks from from
this point forward
yeah they're obviously discussing what
went wrong
perugia will be back to the drawing
board on that one
not the night or if he planned
uh today
and
i don't i don't think that english
attack prep almira is something that jan
maybe had for the world championship
because i don't think he ever would have
thought that magnus is playing in night
or if it's not really part of his
repertoire but that was that was a very
very impressive victory from yonda
pombashi and he is at this point the
clear tournament leader
and also if well if you're playing
against yann nipomnishi
this is not the opening that you would
want to play against being because it
gives him the opportunity to show all
his potential you know so do you go
i don't know for the berlin defense yeah
no of course it's not the right opening
for yon and the result says so he now
has two wins
dingley wren and now against ali reza
farouja
this guy
this guy has shown that he's the man to
be perhaps we need we all need to check
ourselves before we wreck ourselves
thinking that a yonder palmishi who lost
to magnus carlson
wasn't going to have it here in madrid i
mean
hello you just said this is exactly the
type of opening that allows yon to show
what he's best at right great prep in
super sharp positions going to play
going to play fast and out calculate you
that's not the kind of position you want
to play against yonder pawn machine i
don't i don't know that uh we're going
to see many more niner sicilians against
him
and how many rounds yes we have three
more rounds to go in this first half of
the tournament
his next opponent is going to be hikaru
that's a great one playing black against
icaru is going to be quite the challenge
after for after beating farouza but
before we move on for that let's
actually see how it compares to the
other player who just finished of course
aldi reza ferruga
he uh
does not have the same result in this
round four it is a loss to yon
napomnishi
how do you recover from your ferugio
well i guess you have to be happy that
you have two whites in back-to-back
games versus young christophe duda and
fabiana carwana
yes i started with three well three
blacks of course it's a very difficult
start for his first candidates also
so his preparation was tested and well
now he will have to show what he has
in store i think
and that's a good point elmira that i
think if you're an ollie reza ferocious
camp the confidence booster because it's
all about getting keeping yourself in
the right mindset is like look
you had three out of four blacks to
start
right
and
the one time you had white your
preparation was on point and it took
brilliant defense from someone to
survive so this tournament is far from
over you've lost a game
no big deal
right move on nbd that's french for
move on
right i think so so he's gonna he's
gonna move on and try to use the white
pieces in his next two games
and all that said
regardless of what farouz's camp is
feeling and obviously getting him in the
right mindset super important for the
young player for for the next couple
games you have to just tip your hat
right now to the feed a candidate's
tournament that yonda palmishi is having
just amazing stuff um
and that is the only game that is
finished everyone else we are now
looking back at
report and car and nakamura
wow okay that's going to be interesting
we got a lot of chess ahead three more
games to go but um
before we before we dive back into it
we're going to take a quick moment to
remind you that the third annual
youth speed chess championship the chess
kid usb chess championship is just
around the corner
and uh going to be awesome as as i've
always said
you never know when you're watching the
stars of tomorrow
you got to know ali reza faruja in many
ways in online chess events first junior
speeches championships uh we talked
about jeffrey jung holding down the
commentary these days pretty sure one of
the first events we had on chess kid he
won back when he was a teeny teeny
little kid shout out to jeffrey by the
way so who will be the stars of tomorrow
sometimes they're playing in these
events and you can catch all the action
starting june 20th on twitch.tv chess
kid fun master mike and hungry craw
happy crocodile katie
said salva sveli and maria rodrigo so
tune in
to the chess kid usb championship
let's see how this one plays out i think
we're about to see a finish here
between report and nakamura so
don't go
this this particular game i think is
about to have a handshake for a draw
so we're actually we're actually holding
on we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
stay right here before we head to a
break because we know that nobody wants
to miss the handshake i'm gonna get the
board over there my apologies for that
we see a smile
from hicaru and the score sheets have
been signed and on that note you knew
hikaru was ready to go home elmira
because he put his jacket back on
talking about the jackets
we know that richard spends all of his
prize money on the jackets i think he
must be because he has got style
report has has been sporting a fancy
different suit on every single day so
far
um
hikaru just said he wasn't sure about
before idea i read i read lips read a
little bit of lips like jokes aside not
even bad lip reading um
but uh okay reported nakamura is
immediately the second game done here in
round four
hey caro gave a little bit of a push
but report returned the favor on the
queen side they kind of say yeah let's
go for sushi sounds good i know a great
place right on the corner
cool
you're repeating yourself what sushi was
yesterday or before yesterday
yesterday
loves sushi so i don't know how often he
eats sushi but i'm sure he's found the
best sushi places in madrid uh
if i don't say so myself but okay
now as we take a look at the bird's eye
view and two games that will not be
ending
anytime soon we are going to take a very
quick break
um
young christoph duda is is thinking
about his game
and there's dingley wren seeing is there
any way i could keep an advantage here
against fabiano caruana who is uh
swindling his way to an ending where the
extra pawn doesn't matter so we'll be
right back for the remaining two games
here in round four of the 2022 fiji
candidates from madrid and just a few
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
[Music]
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chess variants and with any starting
position you want club arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
the feed a candidates is the most
important tournament in chess
taking place every two years the
candidates qualifies the victor to
challenge the reigning world champion in
a world chess championship title match
the 2022 candidates will feature eight
of the world's best chess players
they've all earned their spots through
two years of fierce competition they now
head to madrid spain where everything
will be settled over the board
one of those eight spots is always
reserved for the previous world chess
championship challenger jan napomnishi
would love nothing more than a second
chance at the throne but he has to get
through seven other great players in
madrid first
two spots went to the top finishers of
the most prestigious open chess
tournament in the world the feedahs.com
grand swiss ali reza faruga won the
grand swiss turned the heads of everyone
in doing so and has become the youngest
player in history to cross the 2800 evo
rating barrier he would become the
youngest world chess champion of all
time should he win the candidates and
ultimately the world chess championship
match
fabiano caruana joined him taking the
other spot from the grand swiss the u.s
number one and third highest rated
player in the history of our game is
also the only person to never lose a
classical chess game to magnus carlson
in a world chess championship match
two of the spots were claimed by the
winners of the dramatic 2022 fide grand
priest cycle
grand master hikara nakamura is a former
world number two a blitz and bullet
chess legend and the most popular chess
streamer in the world
he was joined by gm richard report the
hungarian number one is one of the most
creative and dangerous minds in the game
today and nobody is looking forward to
facing him in madrid
fide awarded one of the eight spots to
the wild card invite grand master tamar
rajaba
raja missed the 2021 candidate cycle in
consideration of covert concerns but as
the oldest most experienced player in
the field he's looking to use that
knowledge and punch his ticket to the
world chess championship title match
and finally
two spots go to the top two finishers of
the world's largest knockout tournament
the absolutely grueling feed a world cup
young christophe duda the polish number
one punched his ticket by ousting none
other than world champion magnus carlson
in the semi-finals of that event
judith would ultimately defeat karjakin
in the final to win the world cup
however karjakin due to suspension from
play by fidei sees his spot go to
china's number one grand master dingley
rent
dingley rent takes the spot due to being
the highest rated eligible player
according to the may 2022 fee day rating
list
so that's how each of our eight
competitors earned their bids to madrid
inside the palace of santona it's about
who can sustain the mental endurance to
secure the coveted slot as challenger
for the world title
but we're not sure who that will be just
yet we do know this
we'll enjoy watching every minute of the
candidates with the chess.com community
as we see how the most important
tournament in chess plays out together
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more
try it for yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
do
these players are stars everywhere they
go but especially here in madrid and
perhaps none
more so than hikaru nakamura this guy is
mobbed
daily on his way to the palacio de
centonia shout out to chris right there
next to him making sure no one is like
all right last autograph that's chris's
job at some point to say he has to play
a game
but hikaru nakamura this the people have
turned out for this guy
and um
they're i wonder if he's gonna have to
start taking a different path
to to
to the palace on different days right
because at some point if it gets a
little bit too much
anyone following the news on chess.com
you've seen the thumbnail to some of our
articles you've seen pictures with fans
those are not staged hikaru his stardom
i'm not sure if he thought as a top
chess player
he he would ever experience that level
of fandom but
to be honest like
i'm becoming a huge fan myself because
i've seen hikari analyzing his difficult
game against elira zafiruja once again
for his fancy he took his time
like when you are taking it uh during
some other tournaments well i would feel
that that's okay but that's one of the
most important tournaments in his life
he's still doing so and i think
this shows like how much he wants to
give yeah to his community no you're
right i mean the hikaru like
these videos where he's giving the
breakdown of
what was going on for him in the game
the level of analysis the honesty with
which he's sharing it we've never had a
top chess player doing that giving that
type of insight that type of look it's
um
it's literally game changing and so
you see his game
this round is done um let's take a look
at how he's done
through four rounds so far here in
madrid
started out with a lost immediately
bounces back with a super impressive win
now a couple of draws
still i would argue his most impressive
game was the draw against verusa elmira
uh of course and now he has two whites
so it's
very important for him
yeah i had that i had the car game upper
that was the final position he just had
against uh
richard report but we'll keep the i'll
keep this game right here
but the um
yeah i agree i think the two whites
coming up for hikaru almira very
interesting storyline we'll see uh maybe
maybe hikara could be the guy who
catches yonda pandashi right we said
it's catch me and you if you can because
napoles is in the clear lead maybe
everyone in the field is rooting for
hikaru to get a victory with white but
okay we talked about hikaru let's talk
let's take bring up reports uh
score card if you will so far
reports report card
well um
it reports that there are four draws the
four draws right there you go he's he's
held on it's funny i don't think it
totally tells the story um he had a
really interesting game um as black
versus duda
um survived against dingley red
yesterday where dingley wren where you
know was pushing and maybe had a crazy
opportunity and he was completely
winning against uh russia and and he was
completely winning against ferruja
but
but yet he stands with four peaceful
results so yes but all of these draws
are very hard fought you know and
it doesn't reflect uh once again
on how
intense these battles were yeah
no i think that that's that's a good
point so the score the scorecard for
report does not tell the full story
um of how he got those four peaceful
results he has the opposite of hikaru
ahead of him though two blacks back to
back uh where hikaru has two whites
coming up so
we'll see how he can hold up with the
second move against caruana and rajabovs
respectively so
here we've got the bird's eye view
three of the four games done already
you know we we haven't seen the
the draw between yeah we should we
should
find a way to just also quickly tell
people you know the dude or jabba
through their game it was
it's hard to say it wasn't wasn't boring
game but just you know i don't know we
didn't get a chance to look too deeply
at it and it ended while we were at the
break so apologies for that but um
we'll find a way to give a quick look at
that before the show's done everybody
but okay let's let's go to the stingley
rent car won a game because
i feel like we've been saying it's just
a draw
you've been saying i've been saying that
but
it certainly has a lot of drawing
tendencies but a pawn is a pawn a pawn
is a pawn and it's an extra one on c5
so
fabiano needs to bring his king
closer to the sipon of course
white
will probably continue with kingi to
king d3 as well
one of the funny things about the c pawn
as compared to like the b or the a pawn
in this type of setup is
often when you have an outside pass pawn
elmira you're never threatening to take
it and trade to the king and pawn ending
because the the opponent's king is too
close
with the sea pawn that's not the case
right you you literally can put your
king in front of the pawn and and trade
and
your king is is more than close
more than likely to hold on in the end
game so
um
i was thinking about rook b2 but does it
lose
after roxy ford so
white loses the c pawn
that's because
i want to play with b7
but then after rook c4 b7 king f6 roxy 7
[Music]
how can you activate rook well he likes
your move rook b2 oh no
that's not a good sign but
yes the line that i was analyzing was
roxy
so rugby seven
king of six
let's have a look yes rugby seven
king of six you need to protect rook c7
and what
do we think about this position here
maybe e5 to play with king e6 and king
to bring the king closer
yep
e5 for black allows the king to come to
e6 and over
the
e5 king e6
is the idea
and probably
probably
the more i look at that black is black
is potentially in trouble because the
king is sort of frozen to the e6 square
to hold on to the pawns
yes which means the the improvement of
the rook on the seventh rink is that you
can never get the king here to offer the
trade because you'll lose the house
then i will also play rook c2 and keep
an eye on all of your buns
that's fair
maybe you need to play it right away
right
do you remember what we were
i was telling you about the rook and
games the more i look at them the like
the
i have the feeling that i don't know
anything
rock endings are just
the more i give the feelings
you dedicate you dedicate a lifetime
to feeling like you know nothing when it
comes to work endings
yeah rook c2
what can we do here can we
play in the same manner like uh in the
other position we try to play g4 h4 you
need to do something here
i think this is why they say well all
rook endings are drawn
because
what to do okay it's funny bobby
actually doesn't like this setup you
know with letting white get the rook to
the seventh rank is not in his fancy
so he brings the rook back to a7 instead
and then plays king to d7
that actually seems even cleaner because
i think that
i think that if dingley rent had
controlled the seventh rank we would
have been that would have been that
would have been tough but now he'll get
the king to c6
even if white gets the king into d4 or
c4
there's all kinds of threats like rook
a4 check kicking the king back
i think i think bobby chose the right
defense which is weird because that was
by the way that was not the active
defense that was the passive defense
well but he's a phone down already so he
would need to sacrifice another phone
i'm just saying that divoretsky is not
always right that's what i'm saying all
the all the craziness out there
i agree with you but here uh let's
continue king the seven king d3 okay
king
king c6
uh king c4 just in case so rook a4 yeah
rook b4 uh yes rook b4 and then rook a2
yes something like this so room b6
you would go king c7
and what can we do here
offer draw
which phone don't let black win
no but i'm certainly given one one pound
away and then i will try to play
something like ah rook a6 you can play
king b7
i wanted to to check you
so you're going to give me a pawn and
then play
but you will play around with seven but
then it's a draw oh i guess so
that's
that's actually a cool little idea there
because i think your idea is interesting
on mira that if
if you don't play king b7 i'm sorry
uh
yeah like rook a6
if you take
right
now this check
and takes like this gets a little bit
interesting maybe white has some weird
chances although even here what are we
talking about there's no idea this is of
course this is a draw
this is
probably
probably we are on pace knock on wood
for the shortest round we've had so far
at the 2022 feed a candidates in madrid
and not not because necessarily wanted
or not i mean but at this point we saw
an incredible
performance from yond upon rishi a
dominant victory over ali raza faruja
a couple of other draws
maybe one a little more interesting than
the other
but
i think dingley run is down to his last
last bullet last bullet i guess you
would say
and bobby has a
bobby has a shield i guess
the point is this is this is hard to
what can we try because i can i can stop
analyzing uh so maybe rook b8
if king d3 king c4 doesn't work should
we try something a bit more active
rook b8 with the idea of playing rook h8
and creating a weakness
if he plays if dingley rin plays rook b8
in this position the one you're looking
at
that would mean he's uh he's here for
the fight
he wants more than a draw he's going to
do everything he can to try to trick
fabiano
will we have liftoff
oh but
he's going to lose the c pound enough to
repeat
well he knows that this is a draw now
i understand because rugby 8
uh can you play king c6 immediately
but i think of brookie the first thing
you should do is go after the pawn with
like rook c7 because if rook f8 you can
go back to e7 yes that's the easiest
right
okay well we have liftoff we do have
rook b8 we'll see how quickly fabiano
plays rook to c7 i think
i think that's better than getting the
king too far away from the pawn
structure
although king c6 might also be drawing
the point is if you keep the king over
here then you know when you go for the
pawn you play g6
rook g7 you defend f7 you you make sure
you lose this pawn which is the easiest
pawn to lose you regain the pawn and now
you have a new four on three
but one that is very very solid for
black to hold in that kind of position
yes but what i wanted to show is just
just in case if you play looks king c6
let's say rook c8
just wanted to illustrate something then
let's say king d7 maybe now
maybe now i can go rook h8
you know you're forced to play h6
then i will play
rook g8 okay it's some sort of
artificial in a way or
maybe something ah no i win rook h7
immediately yes you see so you cannot go
h6 here no i wanted to play g4 yes i
didn't like h i was going to say i i
still want to go for the g6 idea and
just give you the pawn
because i'm
or i guess maybe i'll play king c6 now
oh king six okay but then can i play g4
h4 and by the way he's going for your
idea so you're and we see the eval bar
showing some spiciness so hold the phone
everybody
hold the phone
but i'm trying to find something you
know yeah no i think this is actually
interesting so rook to b8 is played and
then rook h8
bobby did play rook c7 by the way which
was best so
okay
well maybe you're not holding the phone
we were i realized everything we were
just looking at almeira was was kind of
based on
not playing rook c7 which is by far the
best move in fabiano big surprise finds
the best move
um
because now i think on rook h8 he'll
play
g6 first
or king e7 first they're both fine
because rook h7 you play g6 which by the
way is key because it not only defends
the pawn it guards h5
so there's no way for the rook to defend
the pawn and create any kind of mess
so
ding
ding put up the best try but fabiano
his approach
is going to hold i think as soon as he
plays g6 he's guarding the h5 square
now again
i guess we i guess this game you know
might be going on for a while right how
how badly does dingley wren want to get
the w as white is the question here
the w with white
well he wants to play to create the best
pawn he wants to play g4 h4 and h5
and
think for a while
you should be careful well you're not
losing europe but i can play king f8
king jade and simply take on h5 then
it's just that's also that's funny um it
doesn't quite work but it is funny that
like if h4
you know i'm just showing some funny
ideas
actually actually isn't good because h5
you're getting out no no not here for
example h4
c5 yeah g4
because well you're not marking so h5
you're still getting out because but
okay it's a funny idea to try to trap
the book here that is one awkward thing
to be aware of
another thing to be aware of is of
course time control
even though the players are
likely likely reaching mu 40 with plenty
of time to spare they still have a
couple moves to make with only six
minutes if your dingley rents so don't
fall asleep big fella
don't get too distracted by the
beautiful art in the palacio des antonia
you ever been so distracted at the board
that you didn't realize it was your turn
like even while you were at the board
yes it happened to me actually once yeah
because if it was ever going to happen
it would happen in a place like this
there's way too many things to look at
here
well actually once we played the
tournament with the part of the women's
feeder grand prix and we played in
in monaco
but in the rooms which are not open to
to general public at all these were one
of the most
old rooms in the casino and it was the
same kind of setting and surrounding
first of all you were looking at the uh
well
at the frescoes like they were
everywhere you couldn't concentrate and
then also there was some
gaming going on
on the side
i it's it's happened i've been at the
board where my opponent moved and i just
i was just lost and thought and then i
looked down i was like
two minutes have gone by what is going
on usually not more than a little bit
but it happens i've been robbed yes sir
move 38
two more moves to make for fabiano
to reach mu 40.
uh same for dingley wren
getting a little distracted by the yard
um
well he doesn't look very inspired he
doesn't look very inspired but okay this
is
this was an interesting one i think
fabiano gets the gets a lot of credit in
this game for for how this happened i
mean remember he sacrificed that b6 pawn
that was a moment that had us
you know
a little on edge there okay you're down
upon the computer also says hey white's
better but it just tells you the
advantage of players the advantages
players need at this level to get a
victory is so much
that's a big decision to play a five a
lot of times in these rook endings you
tell yourself to just sit tight
what is the what is the idea with this
f5 move
well first of all it stops g4
and it okay
and it makes sense you stop g4 and you
have a few squares extra squares for
your king
i like it
it's funny because what is the is there
a diveretsky rule for
you know
so many times
the the recipe for disaster is actually
moving your pawn in these rook endings
right keeping things together is often
the best way to hold
these four on three three on two sort of
rook endings
but this position here
fabi takes an active approach if you
will he's going to put the king on f6 he
does so already and he wants to play e5
i think yeah he wants he wants to he
wants to actively defend this thing
right e5 e4
maybe not e4 be a little careful
move 40 has been played by dingley wren
not quite yet for
fabiano time control will probably have
us you know
look around
take a break
meeting the players take a break from
the board
plays rook to c4
and g3
maybe e5 now or he doesn't want to
to push it immediately
maybe
simply keep your hook on the on the
fourth like
b4 look c4 k4
yeah fourth rank is how you hold
and there's no real way in fact
i think if fabi will probably just play
a move like rook a4 here
and then dingley wren has not gotten up
from the board he's aware that he
reached time patrol but maybe he doesn't
have anything else better to do but
let's stare at the board right
um
which is uh
which is what you're here to do so
that's okay although one thing we will
do for those of you who subscribed today
on the show you probably noticed that
there was a face
at the end of that notification
that face was the tournament leader
heading into the round
it was fabiano carwana's face tomorrow
it's going to be a new face
well i haven't seen that you know i
haven't seen anything
here in just a second we'll see it
um
and when uh
when you see that face tomorrow and
beyond the palm beach's face he is
officially the man to beat
gets the black pieces versus hikaru
nakamura so i cannot wait for that but
um
anyway don't worry favi your face might
be back there
and we just froze
we just froze we just paused because
right now
there's uh
well i then you move i think
draws here
there it is you see bobby's face
okay you guys see it
gilbee 3-2
tomorrow that face is going to be yonder
palmishi
and uh
we will keep it updated with whoever the
tournament leader is throughout the
event just little fun little kicks and
gigs for all of our subscribers
we're doing what we can
being creative
um
well let's provide some instruction in
this in this thing might as well
talk about why we look at this position
and say it's just a draw i think maybe
take for granted there in fact look at
that
we've already updated the face to a new
smiling yonder pondishie looking good
john
feeling good
hollywood um
okay so
one of the reasons why this is an easy
draw elmira is
we have to kind of like
we have to go like
way forward to help people understand
right that like rook endings because of
the geometry of the board right you're
literally dealing with straight lines
the rooks challenge each other so well
they also limit the the opponent
advances so well that unless you have
something to sort of distract a rook it
often is the piece that can set up the
easiest like blockade like just cuts off
a file or cuts off a ring to get really
basic right if we're just talking about
why so many rook endings are drawn right
and so when you have a single pawn
advantage if you take everything off the
board what often happens is a rook is
doing the same thing it's doing here
and eventually
you get all the way up the board in a
similar fashion where the rook is has
been cutting you off the whole way and
when you finally push one square too far
the king that is just sitting in front
being the black king stays there and
this rook flips down and just starts
giving checks and the point is because
again the geometry of the board the king
literally has nowhere to go this is i'm
in a very abstract way i'm describing
the philidor defense in a rook ending
and but it's it's because of the
geometry that there's just
the rooks rooks hold against a single
pawn advantage as well as maybe any
other single piece end games besides an
obscure bishop ending against a single
pawn advantage and it's just because of
the dynamic of the straight lines that
we play on right the map is limited as
the kids would say right this is not a
video game fortnite map where they're
always doing crazy things to make you
think that fortnite's as cool as chess
fortnite is not as cool as chess i'm
here to tell you okay
um this is this is a map of concrete
maneuvering and the point is
rooks
do a very good job of defending progress
because of
the dynamics of a chessboard did i
describe that well in a little with a
little bit of a geometry lesson no i
liked it very much i think maybe we can
do it also on the teleprompter where we
can show affiliate or position because
it's a very important theoretical
knowledge that you should have
when you defend your games it's so it's
very important so yeah it could save you
a lot of points
and here uh well we
we think that this is a draw because in
order to make some progress white will
probably exchange some of the bonds so
we will inevitably come to this position
that i was talking about yes exactly
right there is no way that you will
avoid those exchanges
uh and
fabiano will simply wait and see like
you will play rook a4 or b4 rook c4
100 so
all right well hopefully you enjoyed
that sort of abstract recent lesson i
think fabi will probably give us that
lesson on the board in one way or
another
uh today but he's one of two players in
the field who has won the candidates the
other one is now the clear leader but
let's remind everybody of who fabiano
caruana is the amazing career that he's
had in our next chess.com player
highlight
no stranger to the candidates fabiano
caruana stands as a pretty popular
choice for winning it all here in madrid
fabi won this prestigious tournament
four years ago in berlin
in his challenger match against magnus
carlson caruana came just one end game
moment away from his first world
championship
i wasn't
wasn't playing my best chess today and
buying this so
i think played
played very well
soon to be 30 karwana's chess resume is
matched by few in madrid
born in miami with dual citizenship fabi
became the youngest grand master in u.s
history at age 14.
a decade ago he made history at the
sinkfield cup winning seven straight
games on his way to a 2844 rating the
third highest of all time
precise calculation and deep knowledge
of opening theory are fabi's calling
cards the italian-american used both to
great effect in the fide grand swiss to
qualify for this event
caruana now aims to become the first
player since vishy anand to win the
candidates in non-consecutive years
but perhaps more importantly fabi looks
towards another shot at the world title
fabiano caruana
many people's pre-tournament favorite
coming in
and uh for good reason this is where he
stood coming into this round versus
dingley wren and if he holds a draw that
helps that little that that scored
deficit he had coming in here elmira
uh well of course
first of all it's very important like to
to win games in this tournament but
what's more important is not to lose so
when you see this result you know like
plus one so it means like one win and
three draws is a perfect you know start
for this very difficult tournament
the most important is not to lose yeah
so like in the pocket to remember the
chips you are losing the other way more
important than those you know that
you're you're winning so that's a really
good point you people always remember
like the sexy all-in
push right but the chips you don't lose
are just as important the decisions you
didn't make maybe the best decisions
that you made but um
well he's uh
of all the people in the field
i think one of the things that's been
interesting about following fabiano is
that
it's not just that he's played magnus
before i think a lot of people feel like
of everyone in the field he might be the
best challenger to carlson if he got
through i know people want to see
farouza the youngster okay nakamura
carlson would literally break the
internet um with with hikarus following
but i think pound for pound people still
look at fabiano as the only guy to never
lose a classical match against magnus
carlson in a world championship match
right and should a couple of other
things have gone his way in 2018 he was
close right so i think i think for my
money when i look at it i feel like
maybe that's one of the other biases
people have about not just whether
bobby's the favorite here but he might
be the only person who who could who
could put the test to carlson what do
you think
well from this tournament of course but
i remember also that
sergey kirakin had magnus on the verge
of lewis on the verge of losing the
match of course this match was also um
very tense and
carrick and was leading yeah
so
yes enough one element which is also
very important is that
fabiano has improved in
in blitz and rapid
because you know some may criticize him
and said okay he will not stand the
chance in in the tie breaks but that's
that is no longer true i think so i
think that's a very important point and
and by the way as i say that fabi may be
the best challenger for carlson that's
no disrespect meant to other players i i
even thought that john upon michi i gave
you on great chances against carlson in
fact i even picked him as an upset
winner in an interview i did for chess
life and my argument was that elmer i
was like hey if yon can get to rapid and
blitz against carlson he might be a very
different opponent than magnus has ever
faced in tiebreakers i think he would
have been a bigger challenge than both
carwana and karjakin were at that time
right so no just so again and of course
if you talk about hikaru nakamura or ali
reza farruja or anybody they all have
i think different strengths about their
game that could give carlson a challenge
so again
no disrespect meant to the field but
there's a reason fabiano has has reached
the third highest rating ever in chess
behind kasparov and carlson so there's a
reason fabiano didn't lose a classical
match to carlson right and that's why a
lot of people look at bobby and
feel the way they do so
and
we see rookie four being played on the
board it's kind of what we predicted
he's just going to hold the fourth rank
and so again on that on that note that
out and mounting pops away we've got
that great moment in chess where neither
player is at the board
and there's a lot of time left on the
clock the most exciting event in sports
right behind sudden death dodgeball
um
anyway the um
the uh
to the point again that almira said to
back up what i was saying if you use
your imagination and take all the pieces
off besides one extra pawn for white
whatever pawn that is
you see that the rooks hold and if the
pawn pushes too far eventually the rooks
check forever and the floodgate opens
but the problem that almira backed it up
with is that
that type of future we're forecasting in
our crystal ball
is kind of the only future you have here
because how else do you make progress
there's no
you know maybe you want to try to move
the king around
advance the pawn exchange so that when a
trade happens you can change the
structure right you kind of split the
pawns in a way that's one way to make a
weakness is to split the pawn group
uh
otherwise the only way you would ever
break down a perfect defense is to have
another weakness
principle two weaknesses right so so
again
for the people watching who sometimes
feel that you know
chess commentators jump too far ahead
and say oh it's a draw like that's not
you know meant in any bad way chess
chess played perfectly sometimes is a
peaceful result and and that gives us
the appreciation and the love for when
we see those victories like we just did
from de palma she but the reality is you
look at a game like this and outside of
some crazy blunder or someone you know
falling asleep like this this is going
uh to be a draw but all right the
players are going to play it out we're
going to learn some things along the way
um
but before we dive back into what's
happening let's remind everybody of
another event that's upcoming
blitz champs baby i'm super pumped for
this and every time i think about how
long it and grueling and awesome the
candidates is going to be i get even
more excited when i realize i'm flying
home to the states to do commentary with
my boy john urschel
uh for these superstars to play july 9th
and 10th it's larry fitzgerald it's
micah parsons it's amari cooper cave on
thibodeau it's a hundred thousand
dollars on the line to charity
uh these guys are picking picking their
charities often many of them have their
own charities already
uh but uh the money they win will go to
their charity and uh it'll be going down
in the afternoon specific time july 9th
and 10th make sure you tune in to twitch
to youtube all of our all of our chess
tv stations you can go to go.chess.com
blitzchamps to learn more about the
event so
why yes i wanted to ask you a question
for example okay well
yes
you want to ask it right now
just
if we compare those football players to
chess players like how would you rate
them because it's interesting to me like
i mean larry fitzgerald is an nfl hall
of famer okay he's he never won a super
bowl
um
god that's an interesting question i
should be good at having a quick answer
i would say all of them
are 100 grand masters
several of them super grand masters as
far as their stardom and like it'd be
like someone like larry fitzgerald is
liking a vaughn chuck okay right or like
a corchanoy or you know someone who has
played at the top of the game for 20
years and just never won a championship
is that a good comparison okay yeah
larry's a bit of a headliner and many of
the others are pro and i would say if
we're saying anyone who makes the nfl is
a gm if you're making pro bowls you're
like a super grand master you're like
the best of the best and then there are
people who are making pro bowls it's
like trying to handle level football for
15 plus years that's like a larry
fitzgerald those are guys that are he
never won a championship but it's a team
game so it's a little bit hard to
compare but anyways that's a good
question okay i like that all right all
right
well we're gonna we're gonna take a
quick break while fabiano takes a think
making sure that he uh
doesn't do anything silly to mess up his
blockade but we will be back with more
of the action it's round four of the
2022 feed a candidates from madrid when
we return
chess online or learn how to improve
join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
hello
this club is called amigos del retiro
friends of the retiro the retiro is uh
the most big and important park in
madrid it's a very important part in the
city because it's right in the center if
you want to play chess you don't know
the place this is a
maybe best one in madrid
puntos
[Music]
this is going to be a real-time
breakdown of danny wrenches games all
time on chess.com uh that's cool
oh
in the last month i am playing 83.12.
i'm less accurate than them in every
stage yeah man that that stains a little
bit okay do the more game review okay
yeah thanks a lot okay so tuesday sucks
i gotta stop playing cats on twitter oh
it's because it's final tuesday
[Laughter]
look how many blunders there were back
in december 2020 and now december 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number
best let's go to
uh tactics
mates
you'll probably need to work on these
ones yep
every single rook fork that has
presented itself to me i have found
no one has a higher percentage of rook
forks than i do
that's correct
these are literally the night forks that
you i missed knight d6 it you saw it
just now what is wrong with me
i could have done here and then taking
this pawn and i'm winning because my
pawns get held together that's probably
the coolest part about this feature like
these positions against pass
rook there for rookie too
and he plugged his maiden one
oh my goodness
i'm awful
[Music]
do
it is
getting late in the day here
in madrid
many people
right outside the palacio de santonia
we see a nice afternoon the weather oh
man the weather has gotten so gorgeous
here in madrid it has cooled down so
much
for those who were for those who were
worried
about you know
about us thank you
thank you for being worried about the
scorching heat that was 40 degrees plus
celsius uh but um it's a beautiful
beautiful afternoon we might even get
outside today i'll mirror before the sun
sets oh shocker that was another dream
about this that would be the first time
uh for any of the rounds we've had
we're right back here you know the one
thing i observed at the break that was
newsworthy if you will is that the
moment dingley wren played g4 and the
capture the table base said i got you
babe it's a draw that that eval bar
changed from whatever it was
previously it had been
sitting around the 50 50 mark if you
remember and then the trade happens
rook takes g4 was played and we have a
table based draw so kind of cool feature
um to see and
you know it's sometimes helpful to know
that you know you know what's really
helpful earlier is we've had we've had
exciting uh games where
it goes to a table-based draw but then
somebody blunders and then it comes back
and that's when you lose your bleep
you're like oh my god what that and
that's usually a fun moment because it's
really instructed to break down
you know what might happen but okay
this is just following the uh you know
the script that we you and i laid out
the reason it's a draw is because white
has no other progress to make besides
advancing pawns
and eventually offering trades which
gets us to the end game that we talked
about
well e4 maybe rook g1 check first
yeah maybe rook g1
maybe anything here right well
i think i'm
king of one rook f1
yeah
king of three rook f1 i don't know
how you're going to defend the spawn you
will play kingdom three
it's not shown on screen but if anyone's
following at chess.com events we
encourage you to use our site while
you're tuning along
every single move in this position is a
draw
draw including e5 for black besides rook
a4 and rook to b1 those are the only two
moves that lose
it's kind of funny
e5 is a draw
that's very easy even e5 is a draw no
but that's very interesting yeah that is
interesting by the way twitch guy 225 so
what is the table base that's actually
uh
let me explain this real quick because
it's a very chess specific thing and
it's a very it's kind of an interesting
science project so thank you for the
question maybe the most interesting we
have left in today's game is this
discussion
uh because
so the table base is when the meat is is
is something that was started by someone
named nalimov
and the
the idea the project was to solve chess
backwards to forwards so
obviously we spend a lot of time in
openings and middle games and tactics
and all kinds of stuff but it's very
much like a soviet chess school thing to
approach building your chest muscles
properly they often say you go backwards
to forwards you start by learning basic
checkmates then you go to slightly more
complicated checkmate and you go king
and pawn endings right the soviet school
of going backwards to forwards
but he took that approach to actually
using super computers to solving the
game we have currently i say we as in
humanity started by the limo and the
work that is now done and and you know
i actually
don't even know how many different um
computers might be working on this
project right now but the table base
goal is to
just literally input every possible
position
backwards to forwards so that right now
i believe we're at seven pieces or eight
pieces i was now at eight pieces oh i
didn't know that that's because it's
eight pieces
when the table base first started
becoming relevant it was that with like
five pieces on the board he had done
enough just inputs that the position
could just be solved like it was just
known every possible way then it was six
pieces then it was seven pieces and i
believe someone in chat correct me if
i'm wrong but i believe that we now have
table bases as far as eight pieces which
is fascinating because it's just it's
just heavy lifting by super computers
that's all it is literally solving every
position
none of this means that human beings
can't mess up endings so for those who
hate that it feels like it's sucking the
the oxygen out of the room or changing
the romantic
math puzzle that is chess i don't really
think that's the case at all i think
it's just you know
it's fascinating when you think that
chess is already a game of defined
information and rule sets yet we haven't
solved it and the table-based approach
is to try to move backwards to forward
towards solving the game did i did i
summarize that right well they have
nothing else to say as usual
i i think i summarized that right right
that was all perfect so
so what what what do you let me ask you
this because here's a discussion that
comes with me and robert a lot although
we're getting close to a draw here is
how often do you think table bases are
now being used by top players we know
that engines are being used in opening
prep
are our players using table bases to
study end games yet
well i'm not sure they would certainly
check their games but i think the table
base are very useful also for the
entertainment purposes like while we
watch because it's very difficult to
analyze during the game and we're given
the answers almost immediately yeah that
that gives us an edge you know also like
okay
how how many hours did maxima schedule
spent on understanding how to defend the
end game against fabiano caruana in the
previous candidates and he still lost
the game right and we had a perfect
setup like
after like 10-15 minutes so
yep
it
it's it's funny because i mean i've it's
probably a discussion i should have had
with fabi when we were hanging out for a
month and i i got a lot out of bobby uh
i definitely took advantage of fabi
while he was in what i wanted to say
that these positions are very very
nowhere where the top players would
really need you know to appeal to a
table base right
exactly because what i was going to say
is like it's kind of adding more to that
it's that
even if they could use the table base to
know the answer in their own game the
places where you could actually use the
table base to study
and there aren't opportunities to go
wrong
maybe maybe there's not that many places
right because the patterns the computers
make it look easy it's a super computer
making table based
spit out answer right
but end game technique especially
defensive end game technique is so
difficult also half the time you're
defending an endgame it's not like you
have an hour left on your clock here
they do but a lot of times you're
defending a drawn ending with seconds
right so there's that human element
right so again the table base it's a
fascinating tool for us as entertainers
as commentators it's it's i think super
instructive when you see it go wrong
um
especially if there's like a pattern
that's not understood where like you you
have a takeaway of an educational lesson
to be learned
but yeah it's it's still i think a very
difficult thing to just say that a human
can start looking at the table base i
see before me where every move is
projected as a draw here for black
besides like you know giving up the pawn
and
you know and say that they can memorize
every single move because the human
doesn't approach it that way they
memorize it in patterns and techniques
and themes right exactly that's what i
wanted to say but even when it
illustrates
when there something is wrong and you
weren't wrong
we will need maybe eight to ten moves to
understand why because you need to
establish a pattern so
and this is not easy yep yep no 100
agree
anyway i wonder if over time though
we're a generation as we said who didn't
have computers and then has learned to
use computers even if we did like at a
young age there was the generation
before us that maybe completed their
careers before even having it or very
little
now we have ollie rosa ferrugia and and
many in a generation that never knew how
to think about chess differently than
how stockfish and the neural nets are
thinking about which is crazy right and
it's changed the style i wonder if
there's a next generation topic where
maybe there is something about using the
table bases that we just don't think of
because of how we were taught and how we
learned chess from this backwards to
forward pattern pattern recognition sort
of approach
where maybe they just you know they're
able to see the forest through the trees
in a way that we don't yet it's an
interesting topic because i think that
if we're talking 10 pieces solved we're
talking about you know
ways that we start to see patterns
within how the table base can project a
draw like you know who knows maybe it
does become a part of their studies
right
hard to imagine but you know first of
all this is an absolute math you know
but when
this is a different algorithm you know
in order to establish patterns i think
so it should be programmed a little bit
differently
so first of all yes maybe we'll
go as far as eight pieces night pieces
ten pieces and uh then we'll see if it's
helpful to
revolutionize you know the way we study
yeah because i think one way it might be
useful is even if it doesn't change that
there's no way they can just memorize
all the moves
no way right a human we don't i mean
maybe humans start becoming half machine
that's a different discussion elon musk
you know chips going in heads and stuff
like that calm yourself down elon but
um what i'm saying is like one thing i
could maybe see
is because they've just grown up around
this information information is power
i could have they're already memorizing
so many opening lines i could imagine
them memorizing like just that they know
it's a table-based draw
whether you know how to do it or not and
as we always say half of what can make a
strong player cheat in chess is just
having like someone to tell them that
there's a good move in the position
without even knowing what the good move
is and i think i could see an evolution
of the fact that
as they start to use table bases and
they start to just know like hey i don't
remember right now
but i know this was a table-based draw
and that confidence right that it's like
a bird on your shoulder saying hey this
is a table-based draw could completely
change a chess player's game just by
someone telling you there is a good move
without telling you what the good move
is
changes the way a chess player can
approach a position
well i agree with you once again
you didn't want to agree with me
but i but that was a good argument that
was a good argument okay so we'll
continue
we just had a breakthrough there i
convinced you
um all right this is moments away from
withdrawal everybody
it felt like a closing argument you know
at the court so yes so i i didn't want
you know to
say anything i'll be honest i didn't i
didn't have that argument coming in i
just as as the discussion developed
because i i generally agree with you
there's just no way a human brain unless
we're talking you know chips cyborgs
but then as i thought about it i think
that that's a pretty good analogy
because these days the reason we're so
on top of cheating and so enforcing is
because we know the power of someone
just sending you a buzz that says this
is a position
stop and think that's why that's why
we've invested so heavily in
anti-cheating technology right so if the
same applies for a table base where all
they need to know is that they put
enough work in where they know a whole
bunch more table-based positions they
don't even need to know how they just
need to know that it was and they'll
probably be able to figure it out
well that it means that we should
probably also organize tournaments well
if this would be the case a little bit
differently yes
probably closed rooms vacuum you know so
yeah we'll send them to space you know
to play the world championship suck the
air out of the room i mean
oh man well um
this is getting closer and closer to the
type of position we immediately
foreshadowed in the four on three
everybody table-based obviously agreeing
but again
notice what fabi did bobby's doing
exactly what we said the geometry of the
rook ending would be he kept the rook
over here cutting things off and then
what happens is this look the moment the
white goes too far with the pawns what
does the rook do it switches behind and
is now just going to check
and and uh
you could do it right away you can also
just take but the point is once the
pawns eventually go too far aka changing
the rook's position from here
the rook will flip around
and give checks here
and if you come back to the fielder
position for example if you take on f5
a pawn takes and if the rook would leave
the sixth rank that's where you need to
keep your rook for example if you would
just that would be the perfect defense
sorry what are you saying take with the
bone okay of course you will give checks
but yeah he gave check first
and this just shows as we said the king
is in front of the pawn as elmira said
and it's going to be a drug what do you
think chad is this guy going to is this
guy going to be on the camera side or
the non-camera side oh look does he know
we switched the cameras or is he just
psychic
okay chat over under chances this guy
walks right in front of the camera the
moment they shake hands
i need chat to get active for me on this
one
let's see i think this guy's gonna i
think we're gonna get a good butt shot
his butt is gonna stand right in front
of the camera
am i allowed to talk about this on
twitch you never know with the tos these
days
i'm probably about to get canceled i'm
generally walking the line of getting
canceled in general
in life
but yeah we're going to get a real tight
butt shot
but can we show something instructive
while we're at it we can show anything
instructed i think we've shown it like
the pawn has to take okay just don't
give checks no don't
sit let's say let's say rook b7 rook b7
that's what i wanted to say that your
rook has to be on the sixth rank to like
to keep the fielder's position and when
you push to f6
then you go back of course because now
we have the perfect position for defense
it's about to happen
let's like this you see yeah bobby just
played an active team but the point
elmira's making is this is exactly what
we said the rook holds laterally you
can't make progress eventually you push
and as soon as you do the rook will come
back around
and give the checks for a draw so
i was trying to get back to the live
board there but again it might happen in
front of us yes for a green key he's not
going to play king of eight though king
of fate would have been what al mir was
talking about which is also a draw but
they're just going to repeat three times
shake hands over under chat oh we
my
my team switch cameras
but look how conscious he is actually so
i was wrong he was super even when he
leaned in on on the
other side of the table
he avoided walking in front of the
camera
shout out to our arbiter for thinking
about the fans at home
i love it
look at how look at him he's like out of
the way of every possible camera can we
look at the other angle too is he also
behind that angle
look at that
this guy's a master
well i was wrong
we will not have a butt shot to end
today's show
so jingling is the only player who is um
rated above 2800 in this tournament next
to
because we just saw it you know yeah
yeah
although ratings are just so weird right
now right because of covet and
you know the uh
the setback that it did over the board
chess i mean you see it in different
spots
where players are underrated overrated
notre backup of turoff winning a world
rapid championship
you know despite
if you'll be like what's going on right
even though for the last two years he's
been
really flexing in a lot of online events
so
they're analyzing the b5 line
he's like wait
ah
okay
so father was suggesting that ding had a
better chance
yeah
i totally agree danny wrench is the
worst commentator in the world yeah no
he doesn't know what he's talking about
that's the dumbest stuff in the world
that he would think about that line
yeah i know what an idiot he missed a5
or k6
yeah
i'll never work with chess.com again
the world championship was the worst
experience of my life huh that's so
funny
that's so funny everyone thought you
were having a good time i wasn't danny
was torturing us making us do stuff
behind the scenes
well
i'm just glad it's over
yeah
i'm not sure what i'm gonna do with
myself
okay good talk we're out here
bad lip reading
it is the future of chess commentary but
i think that you would do uh very well
on on the show with jimmy fallon you
know when they're lip-syncing and they
all have to sing a song you know so they
perform
like lip reading songs i would i would
love to use no it's actually lip syncing
you know it's just it's
yeah the other way around i i would be
better at lip singing than karaoke
that's for sure but all right this is
how the day
was won
or drawn depending on where you sat
three draws and one
absolutely brilliant performance from
yonda pomneshi
biggest takeaway of round four for you
elmira
well this is of course uh the win by
yandy pomnishi against uh
alireza roja it's such an important win
especially at this stage of the
tournament it sets the pace you know so
he's leading the tournament now
uh it's very difficult to win to win yet
one game on the tournament but two
it's almost impossible so he is at plus
two after four rounds
we will
see how um how the tournament is going
to develop
tomorrow but
fabiano if he wants to catch him you
might have to push yes he is
is really true like obviously
each game had its own storyline but when
when you get an early leader like this
don't think the players don't know
right what that like all right i can't i
can't keep i can't lose anymore right
and i can't keep drawing if he's going
to continue to maintain the lead so i
wonder how much that was in the head of
of fabiano i mean i don't think that he
could have been thinking about anything
but getting a draw as black against
dingley run today you know there was
really no other goal in mind but
tomorrow what will it what will it do
right and as we move forward
um
if you want if you want to keep face
with yonder palm rishi
you know what he might be doing fabiano
might be rooting for his countrymen
tomorrow with the white pieces against
uh against yonder palm rishi because if
hikaru gets a dub
obviously that would shake up the entire
standing so
okay
uh
speaking of hikaru getting the dub he
only got the draw today but he's he's
gonna have a big a big battle tomorrow
with yon napomnishi
we'll see what his thoughts were about
the game that he just played and
anything else that he and dina bell and
kaya caught up to as she did get an
interview with nakamura after his game
versus report
car it's great to have you here your
game finishing draw please take us
through your emotions during the game
yeah i mean um
let's just say i lost a game in the
rapid chess championship i mean i think
already it's many weeks ago now probably
like
two months three months um but i lost
the game in this bishop g5 line to
fabiano um and then i looked at this
thing that i came up with in the game
this whole hxg5 bishop e6 thought it was
interesting um
yeah i mean i was all prep up until
about move 20 wasn't very difficult to
find moves but then inevitably like
every other game so far there was a
moment where i got a little bit careless
for two to three moves and maybe richard
had some chance when i i played this
very strange
king king king e5 and this whole rook a1
thing but
again i mean with white not being able
to ever push the f pawn i think it it's
always very close to a draw so i didn't
ever feel like i was in danger but i
mean perhaps i could have been more
precise
we quite seem
sometimes hear g5 in this tournament um
let's say
if you were to explain to your audience
uh why these moves are good uh
like pushing the phone in front of your
king what would you say
well luckily i hadn't castled my king
yet so it's not a complete violation of
the rules because i can castle to the
king side or the queen side there but
you know i think at the end of the day
there are obviously very many levels in
chess and essentially when you start out
you learn all the basic rules and
eventually you learn how to break all
the rules or one when there are
exceptions um
and so that's that's kind of what i
would say is that as you keep improving
you learn which roles you can break
which ones you can't but even beyond
that with computers nowadays they they
pretty much say you can do anything and
it doesn't matter you push the g pawn
you push the h pawn you castle who cares
i mean it's it's all okay so
um i mean sometimes you feel i guess we
as humans feel like we don't really
understand the game but overall it's
just our different level and trust the
game where you learn the thousand roles
and you learn when you can break them
right and uh speaking of uh madrid here
we're an amazing city you arrived quite
early how important is for a player to
let's say acclimate
yeah i mean i think it's quite important
especially if you're coming from another
continent i think i i suspect fabiano
had been in europe for for a while but
um at least for me coming from the us
where there's a six hour time difference
certainly makes a difference but even
beyond that i remember when i played in
2016 i think i got to moscow maybe three
days before the event started and i
never really got on track sleep schedule
or anything i never had a good routine
so
yeah i think it's important to come
maybe a week week and a half early i
mean i know in the old days people would
come like a month early you know the
times of alaska and those guys but
i think a week's enough but it's it's
important to be on the time zone and
feel like you're you're ready to play
you have some great memories connected
with spain you won your first elite
tournament uh actually in spain is there
some kind of aura or some extra power
that you feel here
um i don't know i mean san sebastian was
so so many years ago now i mean that was
what 2009 i think it was so
um you know i feel like i've actually
probably had my best results in spain
and france in particular those two
countries so i don't there's anything
special but i feel like i play well
in these places so that's what it is
perhaps my final question for today uh
how has your audience been reacting so
far to your six
hours long games but then they usually
are used to see you playing three
minutes well i mean i think uh as long
as you're competitive it's always going
to be hype i think uh there's a certain
uh view that the the streamers when they
play tournaments aren't going to do very
well or people want to see that see the
sort of the the car crash or the train
wreck but i think as long as you're
playing reasonably well and then good
things happen that being said i mean
every game like i said i've found a way
to make sure it goes longer than it
should i mean today luckily it didn't
didn't cost me where the game went six
hours but um i mean there's there's
suspense and i think people always watch
that
thanks a lot sure
that was interesting uh what he said
about how
a lot of fans want they want kind of a
train wreck right a car crash and i
think there's some truth to that because
they want blunders entertainment but i
really agree with the summary which is
like hey i'm here
i have a huge fan base and as long as
i'm competitive i know that the fans are
going to support me and be appreciative
and i think he's been pretty
damn competitive so far elmira well i
agree with this and uh what i found
interesting in this interview it's the
way hikaru looks he's very confident you
know and tomorrow we are have we are
having the game between yani pomnish and
hikaru nakamura and jan is also feeling
very confident so this will be a huge
clash
i agree i can't wait and as you see
again it's almost like we've already
forgotten that he started off with a
loss which is kudos to ikaro because he
immediately made all the fans forget
that with his bounce-back victory and
then two very very interesting draws uh
the epic battle with ferruccia and then
today's game that was a i liked his
thoughts there i know we didn't have a
chess board but i appreciated his
breakdown of what happened there with
the king in the center but okay
young napomnishi
hikaru nakamura i should say it the
other way for those who speak chess you
typically say the player playing white
first so hikaru nakamura yondapamrashi
tomorrow are you going to sleep well
tonight are you going to be too excited
for that game first of all i'm going to
prepare and i have to go through their
games
i want i want to find out what are the
openings you know they're going to use i
also had a glance at the stats you know
they're even yup so two wins two losses
so anything can happen
yonda palmer she's at the top of the
standings so everyone knows that as of
now he is the man to beat we were joking
that's leonardo dicaprio everyone else
is tom hanks catch me if you can
and uh who do you think can do it elmira
i certainly think that ricardo can do it
that's that's where it would start right
and again if you're probably on carwana
at this point
you know you're only a half a point
behind so you're probably the only
person in the standings who isn't
changing their game yet at this point
the psychology for fabi is like i just
got to stay the course i'm only half a
point behind nepal had a great win today
versus perugia but not no panicking for
favi yet right and that's where you need
the smaller chair
so he's going to watch this game very
closely yeah he is he's going to watch
this game very very closely so yeah
that's that's actually interesting
dingley runs smaller chair does make it
interesting
to uh to watch the other games oh that's
what he said that he can see yeah and
okay so we've already said
nakamura versus nepal machine tomorrow
that's the highlight let's bring up the
other matchup so that everyone knows
that there will be more games than just
nakamura and upon rishi and karwana
speaking of a guy who doesn't need to
panic he's got a plus record against the
guy he's going up against and richard
report
yes so he leads three to one
which also
is
like i i glanced at 4-0
don't judge yourself that you skipped
past one job
we love them both don't but i also saw
the doughnut 4-0 and items like
ferrucci's record is 4-0 against dude
yes i don't know what and i wanted to
say what because like uh we had
different scores against uh well all the
other opponents and especially there
were no games played but here you have
four to zero that that's what i find
very surprising that's i was thinking is
there a mistake no so
well i mean okay speaking of a storyline
we didn't talk a lot about the youngest
player in the field getting his first
loss
what's going through his head tonight
well i think
you can't pick a better opponent to
rebound against and of course all these
guys are are fantastic chess players
that can also be a trap mindset if
you're too overconfident but that said
ali rezab for aruja does have the white
pieces he does have a 40 score against
duda and then of course as you've
already highlighted nakamura and napan
mishi have both delivered two fatal
blows to the other in their careers
along with five draws to go with it so
um
that's exciting we gotta we got a nice
little uh nice little lineup tomorrow
nice nice little slide ahead i think so
um
all right well before we go
the tournament i'm not playing but my my
partner i was just about i was just
about to throw you under the bus on this
the term my partner here have never
played in one of our online events
almeris kripchenko will change that next
year we have two of the strongest women
players in the world competing in our
wscc the women's speeches championship
continues on friday it's the 2021
quarterfinalists katarina lagno
she's taking on vantika agrawal and uh
manteca has been
kind of a surprise uh star here in she's
a 15 seeds and she's rocking and and
she's uh
anyway it's going to be interesting to
see she i believe she qualified her way
in um and uh has been impressive in
doing so so you're going to want to tune
in on friday it's an early one at 5 00
a.m pacific
on chess.com well i've been following
those tournaments quite closely and
actually criteria like is one of the
best players blitz players in the world
she's won the blitz championships
several times so uh this match is uh
well it's
very interesting it's going to be very
exciting so
well amira it was a good day it's a
short day we're going to get outside and
see some sunlight here i'm pretty
excited about that
uh you can uh
get at us on twitter get at me on
twitter and elmira's official account
chesscom on twitter but jokes aside this
has been this has been fun we've got
round five tomorrow one last shot at the
palacio de santonia dina valencia catch
up with dingley run we're gonna see that
interview tomorrow along with much more
tune in for chess.com coverage of round
five for the feed a 2022 candidates we
will see you then
[Music]
do
you